so
pumped we have our first episode with
zach
marlowe what's up zach it's so good to
be here
oh my goodness i'm here with frank yang
i'm here with and we're back with frank
yang
yes i'm doing this thing that i do a lot
now which is talk to strangers on the
internet publicly
i never do that i do sometimes now i
used to never do that
i used to have this fear of webcams i
used to be afraid of time to figure out
webcam
afraid if i forgot to turn it off and
then when i masturbate the poor people
will see it and then it'll be like
millions of vines and people
like being out because of me just
speaking through this frank remember
we're trying to make this episode
relatable for people
with compassion and collective awakening
yeah family friendly
we're trying to connect the broadest
swath of humanity possible we've got to
facilitate this awakening because
it doesn't matter if there's a way we've
got it figured out
or i've got it figured out or atlas has
it atlas
has it figured out we've all got to get
it figured out
it doesn't mean anything ain't [ __ ]
because of compassion after after
realization i am not scared weapon
anymore
so that's so related after realization
i'm not scared where camps anymore i
talk to strangers now
on webcast you feel any fear
uh before wow i was fearful of webcams
and now i'm not that's it
yeah i don't really i don't really feel
fear anymore i i
maybe i do i mean i i i notice when
other people around me feel
are afraid of things oh yeah generally
bother me
i'll i'll go ahead and just i'll go
ahead and just say that
um just down a very
simple way for people that are watching
what we what we mean um in a very
general
sense by awakening is sort of realizing
the unity of all existence
um and so realizing our oneness and
realizing the love
for each other because we are that that
same universe um sort of exploring
and um and then now what we we do as we
sort of realize that is now we figure
out how can we
um weave uh that
into the mainstream society that doesn't
necessarily feel
oneness and doesn't necessarily feel
harmony and they maybe feel
a little bit you know very stressed out
or very depressed or very anxious or
they feel like
they're locked up in their nine-to-five
job that they can't escape
and so how can we um bring
love and compassion and unity into this
is what
was going to be something like one of
the big themes that we talk about on the
show into the mainstream well i was
thinking about it on the way over here
on the train
and um first of all the train stopped on
the tracks
and i could see everybody around me was
very impatient and was antsy and was
afraid or was angry or was
you know like a friend a friend of mine
was with me and he was like oh when is
the train going to come when does the
train come i was just like
you got to chill you got to just relax
because you know time is a
is a subjective thing you know it it
doesn't really exist in a linear way
it and if you stare into each moment and
you're like okay how much longer how
much longer how much longer it's
literally going to expand it's going to
be
it's going to be longer than it
otherwise would be if you just take that
time
and forget it or do something else it's
like if you're stuck in traffic
you know keeping these practical keeping
keeping keeping this tethered to the
moment i mean
because these are the million moments of
fear and anxiety
and dread not just the moment where the
sword is at your throat and you're like
okay now i need to be cool and calm and
collected it's like
these many many many moments through the
day that it's like we're stuck in
traffic and you're like okay
i'm delayed or you have a layover at the
airport it's like okay i have to kill an
hour
you can spend that hour agonizing over
how late you are or how you're gonna
this is gonna increase the stress in
your life or you can accept
oh okay i have an hour how what i choose
to do with this time i can take a breath
disconnect from this moment disconnect
from this fear this reaction
and you know find some peace find a
center
or do whatever i want or just be just
enjoy myself and i could never do that
as a kid i could never do that for most
of my life
i couldn't just be and i think that's a
core problem that we experienced today
that
so many people through coven 19 just
their life went on hold
and they were stuck in a room for you
know six months or a year
and that was like the end of the world
that was the most traumatic thing that
they've ever experienced
when if you just know how to be with
your thoughts i mean it can be a real
blessing just to
just to be just to not have the you know
run around in this wheel or treadmill
some of us here like the treadmill wait
i was gonna mention treadmills
what about him um when i was younger i
used to just
sprint on the treadmill to try to be the
fastest man in the world
i thought i was the fastest man in the
world because i could turn the treadmill
all the way up
and i was sprint to watch i watch tv so
sprinters spin and i'll try to master
their um the speed of their their their
the cycling of their legs but then i
realized speed is actually the result of
the length
and the speed not just the speeds i was
doing like this
but when i should be in like this i
realized i couldn't be a sprinter
but i started to meditate
i think there's a couple more steps in
the frank yang story there but
yeah i love the relatability of the
example that
marlow just gave because everyone
basically has moments
in every day of their life where they
can tell the difference
between where they have an
opportunity to like take a breath and
sort of regain
some of their sovereignty and will and
choice around
their happiness and to not suffer
to not be anxious to not be depressed
and that those were great examples
you're on the train the train is delayed
anyway
you may as well not perpetually focus
yourself on the delayed train and suffer
and be anxious
but instead liberate yourself from that
be more
free and then enjoy
the nature the clouds or if you want to
read an email and get through something
or whatever you're doing
but not be ruminating on on that
specific thing well it's like as ever
every single uh second of our lives have
been atomized and chopped up into these
like
increasingly small little moments that
each one of those moments each second of
our lives
as if we embody stress and pain and
misery and suffering
becomes a prison every and it's it's
prison to prison to prison to prison to
prison
so i looked i looked up as the uh as the
as i had that exchange with my friend
and i see a girl on the train and she's
reading
a new earth by eckhart tolle and i was
like she gets it
that's a really important point is don't
make your life prison to prison to
prison
like increase your amount of
possibilities
uh increase your choice architecture
as much as possible every single moment
so you're not just locked into just one
excessive anxious rumination
uh so that there's more possibilities
for you
yeah even when you go into the matrix or
going to the prison to still be
perceived as
as infinite because uh nirvana is
samsara
do closing the loop right there thanks
bro
for the person on the train even though
i'm anxious and suffering this is still
non-dual
this is still open it's a little bit too
soon to tell them that
the other day
matrix of reality is the punchline i
think the whole thing is it's very funny
it's really very funny and strong
yourself and look at that we're like
these meat creatures trapped in this
crazy world of minutes and moments and
trains that you know it's just very
weird and
none of it makes sense until like a
panda sitting on a tree they're just
like what the
[ __ ] are you doing chill out but on the
the subject of like explaining
you know the non-dual to the stressed
person on the subway i heard a great
quote the other day was like
uh explaining philosophy to somebody
with a it's cruel
to explain philosophy to someone who is
has an empty stomach yeah
kind of brings me to like the central
point of
what i've wanted to talk about for a
while and you know this episode coming
up
really fits perfectly um for me
because it burns in me and i see
spiritual people i see people who are
enlightened
you know i i even had this conversation
with a friend recently about like
eckhart tolle like oh he doesn't get it
blah blah blah blah
where it's like talking about philosophy
and awakening and all of these things
to the vast majority of people in our
world is an
insult and it's aloof and it will never
be understandable to them
from the framework that they're
operating from because society is
designed
designed intentionally
you know latticed to keep people from
being able to work their way
up that sort of ladder of just basically
meeting their basic needs and
this has been studied from the
sociological perspective and from the
physiological you know neurological
psychological every perspective
people are trapped in a wheel a hamster
wheel not a treadmill on their own
choice
but a a wheel of of labor and servitude
and
they're working 60 hours a week i i
talked an uber driver the other day he
worked 100 hours a week and it's like
you can't if you're so focused on
meeting your next meal
or putting food on the table or feeding
your children or
any of these things that are just pure
survival if you're in survival mode
you can't even delay gratification to
think about
you know anything beyond eating a candy
bar right now it is
physically impossible so it's like it's
more difficult to have metacognition
when your basic needs aren't being met
but it but in a way it's easier because
suffering brings out awakening as well
so
that but you have to have the knowledge
of it well there's a difference
between there's a huge difference
between starvation and fasting
somebody who was in the desert like i'm
going to deprive myself of these
nutrients to induce the state
that person is doing it intentionally
you know
who just has no food in their stomach
and that's all they can think about
they're not going to sli
switch from you know hunger into
enlightenment it's just not going to
happen
i would say the miracle yeah that's what
i'm saying like they can because um
i think suffering drives most people's
process uh progress to awakening
um and also like under really stressful
situations is where a lot of people have
glimpses of non-duality
uh but there's there's definitely a
range to this thing you know like some
that doesn't happen it's not like you
suffer and then you become awake and
it's not like that but
just having to acknowledge of it let's
just say like just for a person who like
suffers quite a lot he has to go from
his nine to five job every day but then
he read ecuador or something like that
he had an idea of awakening that you can
watch your thoughts you can read your
thoughts
he has an idea he put it in his mind
like except in his mind
and then he can if you can apply that in
everyday stressful
uh situations it's actually a really
good workout it's kind of like
construction workers just get buffed
well yeah i mean every single moment of
our lives it can be a yoga
yeah and i think for me i honestly i
don't really meditate
i should i'm slacking on my on my
metacognition
but i i feel like my practice my path is
very external it's about
you know kind of instead of looking
inward it's looking outward and seeing
that
self in everything that seeing that
every person on the train that is you
you know and
what they're going through is what
you're going through on you know the
deepest level that we're all sort of
enmeshed in indra's net
or you know we're all just connected on
this in the simplest way we're all
in it together and so i feel i feel
those people's
struggles and i learn from them and i i
think i have
myself learned and grown through extreme
suffering
but not everyday suffering everyday
suffering is confusing and baffling
it's like when something horrible
happens when a meteor crashes into your
barn and kills your whole family
you actually stop and ask why you know
but if it's suffering on suffering on
suffering
you know endless moments stacked on
moments like needles like a thousand
needles into you every single moment of
your life
you don't really have the time or the
energy or the space between that
to really stop and question what
the hell is going on why people just
react
so we're mostly stuck in this reactive
cycle it's reactive dualism we go from
this
to this from this to this to this to
this
with no latency with no nothing in
between and there are moments of grace
but i think that grace comes
it can come in a freak moment it can
come in a reverberation through the
floor into your pineal gland or
you know just something breaking in your
chakras or you know a kundalini
awakening or something like that but
it often doesn't and it's it's really
tragic to me
you know being a person that experiences
great freedom to see people
suffer when they they ought they don't
need to because
just the joy of alice and i were talking
about this on our are
in a little introductory phone call
we've only talked you know once or twice
we've been sending each other voice
messages too we're talking about the joy
of being
you know the joy of living purposefully
the joy of
the like transcendent beautiful
wonderful joy
of of just standing in your purpose
of literally just being just laughing
and smiling because you exist
and just i just think about all those
moments that i spent one wasting away
you know suffering about things that
don't really matter
or that will go away in a minute you
know being impatient
you know needing a game boy to get
through a beautiful drive through the
mountains whatever
but it's like or or like drinking myself
into oblivion or like seeking if
frank knows about that or like you know
trying to bang hot people or
you know be successful or competitive or
win
or do any of these things that are
really ultimately just
fleshy pleasures that are gone in a
minute that make you feel even worse
after they're gone because you're like
oh now i need another and another and
another
whereas just finding that sense of
purpose of like i'm in my
i'm in my true self and i'm finding that
self in other people
and i'm spreading it that's the great
joy is like to be it
but even greater is to share it
um it's just something i wanted to say
oh okay so with talking about compassion
we have to
first define compassion how it's
different from
empathy because um
in my experience true compassion is what
also calls a cold love um
so basically you can't really truly be
compassionate
unless you completely empty out the self
and that's why awakening and compassion
go hand in hand and the action
whatever action that you take before
awakening
is selfish regardless um and also
in intro in this whole love of
compassion it's not
filtered through the individual body
mind's emotion so that's why it's
difference between that and empathy
in true compassion without the separate
self
when other people suffer you actually
don't feel anything but that also frees
up more space to help them because when
you
see the universe doesn't want more
suffering if you feel the suffering that
other people are feeling you're actually
creating more suffering so that's the
difference between
compassion from the space of the
non-separate self
versus empathy from the space of the
separate self
if you feel if you feel emotion when
other people also feel that emotion
that gets in the way of you purely
helping them out of the universal world
of consciousness
so so i would say that this
there's waking up oh yeah uh yeah the
reaction part of it
but i think i think for me i don't know
that's that's kind of where
i i live that's where i sit most
comfortably is in that discomfortable
space
or uncomfortable space of you know
experiencing the discomfort knowing that
insights are there that lessons are
there
that's where meaning lies and i really
seek it out it's kind of a sick thing
that like
to seek to seek suffering in a way to
see
terence mckenna define the shamanism as
like philosophy through extreme
experience
through seeking out uh extreme
experiences that will really show you
like the poles of duality that will show
you all the way to the end
to the point where they you see where
you you've gone so far in one direction
you really see that it's all a circle
and you go back in the other
that's what i was talking about earlier
too about how like you know suffering
creates some kind of awakening like
it's a catalyst for awakening yeah yeah
the same point
how do you feel like you're suffering uh
really was the
the lubricant or the fuel that that uh
pushed you towards the extreme
experiences i mean and you're you're
a connoisseur of extreme experiences a
true shaman in that
how do you feel like suffering more than
any of those other things that's just
like i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna eat a thousand calories or i'm
gonna lift 500 pounds or
i i think i think suffering was never
really the catalyst for me
even though it is subconsciously maybe
but i i never wanted to eradicate
suffering
i just wanted to like my [ __ ] myself i
just wanted the universe to [ __ ] me
without a
i i wanted i wanted to have more of you
with the universe and that's why i kept
lifting weights and i kept eating those
calories
like i just want to see what's beneath
the surface i wanted to penetrate deeper
and deeper transcend the next level on
and on
and suffering i guess could be the
catalyst of that but but i there was
never a goal for a lot of people a lot
of seekers their goal is to eradicate
suffering like i'm
asking why did you get on a spiritual
path i was suffering but for me it was
just
i just wanted to go unlike we talked
about the first episode i wanted to
know what the first i want to talk about
what the [ __ ] this frankie thing is
i see through that this thing is just a
projection just a hallucination and what
the [ __ ] is doing hallucinating what the
[ __ ] is reality
so that's what that was always my
clinical goal and then
as a byproduct of understanding reality
or understanding direct experience
of understanding consciousness my
suffering has been eradicated by 99.9
percent
so by not focusing on suffering i
actually eradicated suffering
see i it's interesting i i both totally
relate and kind of differ in that
for me it's like in finding and feeling
the suffering of the world it's like
it it's not it doesn't hurt anymore it
it's like
i know i know the greatest lesson in the
world
is contained within that and that to
seek these experiences out
you know to seek out the cry of the
world to hear it and heed it and run
toward it you know i know even in a
you know perhaps in a selfish way in in
terms of self realizing itself you know
all of us being the self not not me you
know i'm myself in a selfish way but
the self as all things you know in terms
of in like krishna krishna consciousness
or christ consciousness
the self in all things to run toward
that pain of the self to realize
that's me crying out that's my own soul
crying out that's consciousness which is
the whole gambit the whole thing in pain
and it's telling me something like pain
is a lesson like when you when a when
you get a stun
bit by mosquito and you itch it's your
body telling you
uh to slap it otherwise it'll just keep
drinking your blood and that's what our
pain is that's what the pain and
suffering in our world is
it's telling us something very very
precisely it's it has a there's a
message for us
and i think when it when we make it all
internalized about oh you know the
kingdom of god lies within or you've got
to look inward
i think we forget that to look inward is
to look outward
is to look at the people around us and
to look inward requires the basic needs
being met
of people which is very big it's an it's
an external thing
to have clean air clean water clean
food shelter electricity education
health care those are external things
that then
enable you to inquire in with the
question who am i
um what is reality and that's a really
important point it synthesizes science
and spirituality it synthesizes
consciousness and physicalism which is
ultimately what we need to do
and to actually to
um tie in what you guys have been
talking about a little bit
is that if you come from a place of
like learning that you can take a breath
like one two
three count to three take a breath
before you react to things
that's fantastic and that that can be
really helpful and you can
go and share that with the world and
help alleviate suffering that way
totally
but the way that in a sense awakening
plays into this
is that if you go quote
all the way in this process of emptying
out all of your conditioning and all of
your separation and all of your ego
and rather than this being something
that is trying to still
extract validation or extract worthiness
from other people instead this comes
as just literally the sun itself
enlightenment comes as just the sun
itself
radiating perpetually onto all
and so you're not actually ever coming
from a place of needing to
get something from other people so it's
almost like the level of
purity of service and the level of
purity of compassion
increases in proportion to how awakened
you are
well it's also you know it the ability
to which you can experience
uh truth awakening love all of these
things i think is
is directly proportional to what others
can i mean martin luther king said
something like for some
strange reason you know i'm not i'm not
mad
i'm not happy until you're happy what
and what affects you affects me and i
think really that's
maybe the fundamental disconnect of our
entire society
and you know you use that word
extraction extraction
multiple times and i mean i think that's
kind of the core
a value system that we're trapped under
which you know it it's
it's like it's like an addiction it's
like
frank can talk about this about you know
meditation kind of breaking you out of
a an addictive mentality an addictive
narrative or an identification
with uh who you think you are and i
think that's
really what we're trapped in in this
world it's it's a
corrosive and extractive belief system a
narrative of who we think we are
that goes all the way down to the to the
deepest levels of what most people think
a human being is or reality is
that a human being is selfish is greedy
uh that you know we're competitive that
the purpose of life is to [ __ ] other
people over and get what you can
and say [ __ ] the rest and this is it's
capitalism it's a system it's an
economic system
that is a zealous economic idolatrous
uh you know false belief system that we
have implanted and spread over the
entire earth and say
and have said you know this ultimate
separateness
that spreads and blankets everything
this sort of anti-christ this
nebulous thing that doesn't really exist
that we substantiate through money and
through
trade and through these economic systems
which are really
the most corrosive you know religious
doctrine in the world
you know these forces are absolutely
and directly keeping all of us from
ascending you know
to a high degree and i see this system
really
penetrate much deeper even into
spiritual people spiritual people still
see themselves
as still see the system itself the way
that our society runs
the way that our consumer cycle is
driven on endless growth and endless
consumption and endless
you know self-interest maximizing
self-interest i see a lot of spiritual
people
you know trapped in this because it's
the deepest unquestioned narrative
the deepest identification and addiction
and i think
i i it it even gets me to the point
where i have really distanced myself
from
the from the conscious movement in a lot
of ways because it's so
pervasive this self-interest this kind
of narcissistic spirituality that is all
about me
all about how i can ascend and then oh
these people who aren't ascending
they're sheep
they're sheep you know they don't
understand anything they don't know
what what's you know happening they're
going to fall behind and i'm going to
ascend
and it this is a toxicity in our
spiritual movement and it needs to be
addressed because
we can't individually ascend you know
it's self-interest in a way
self the self-interest for all of us to
get to the point
where we change these systems we change
these identifications this bad dream of
humanity of human history
and get to a point where everyone's
needs are met so that the purpose of
society itself
the design of society is to work people
up that ladder of meeting their needs to
get them to the point
where they can really figure out what
the [ __ ] is going on
and ascend i think you i think
enlightenment is the most selfish
pursuit in existence
uh it's all about itself um it's all
about the self to the point where you at
the end you flip yourself inside
out so it's all about the self up to the
point where you realize there's
absolutely no self
and then after you realize there's not
absolutely no self whatever action that
you do
is not going to be your decision anymore
so
some people wake up and then they don't
do [ __ ] some people wake up they play
video games some people wake up they do
things for the environment they help
people wake up they become teachers some
people wake up and then
um they become a ceo but after you wake
up anything that you do will be an act
of compassion
that because it wouldn't be it would
automatically be an
act uh not for the self because there is
no self so after you wake up you don't
you see it like we talked about earlier
on the other episode it's like you don't
have agency anymore
so it's like it's not you deciding to do
this i don't have it
i'm not free i wake up and just do what
i'm supposed to do and that's it
yeah it's not like you're not free
either because it's not it's neither
freedom or not free
right exactly exactly yeah you know i i
really
it's a beautiful thing it's the most
beautiful thing in the world yeah i was
trying to explain this to somebody the
other day it's like
she was like oh the world is so crazy i
don't know what to do
like you know i just know i don't know
what's going to happen it's like well
you just accept that no matter what
happens is going to happen
and and really seek to understand like
okay the world is hurting and crazy and
i have a role to play
i thi this earth evolved to me for a
purpose
and a part to play in here and it didn't
involve me to just
participate in its destruction it
evolved me to facilitate growth and
you know sharing and you know the
increase of biodiversity not the radical
reduction
so it's like finding that sense of
purpose why are you in this world
how are you participating in this you
know struggle
this uh adventure of collective
awakening of getting there together of
raising us all up because currently the
whole
social system is dragging us all down
but it's like i really feel
like when i thought when you find that
purpose that way
that when you realize that love is all
there is and you've got to spread it
like wildfire you've got to spread that
[ __ ] like crazy or you just realize
like that climate change is real the
earth is dying and no none of us can
ascend
and you as a spiritual person might
think oh i'm gonna fly away i'm gonna go
to the astral realm
[ __ ] you you know that's not you know
there's nothing that's not spirituality
bro
spirituality is not about extending to
some higher realm of consciousness
so like i said spirituality is realizing
formal engineers are identical and the
form part of it is compat
well for me you can you can look at a
very pragmatic way saying like this
object has no
here in existence i can penetrate it
it's it's holographic
and it's only just particles that are
made up of quanta that are spinning
around and at the core
nothing yeah there's not even quanta
it's just
it's just a it's just this there's just
nothing here okay
but then you can also say this is also
form there's also something
and the the emptiness part of it and the
compassion
the compassion part of it and the form
part of it is identical is that
emptiness manifests itself
in not just the uh the manifestation of
objects but also in like things like
compassion that's why
uh compassion is an emphasize in a lot
of uh it's an emphasis a lot of
traditions
and i also think the reason why
compassion is such an emphasis a lot of
traditions
is because after awakening if you don't
practice compassion
uh it's not it's not a guarantee that
you become passionate even though like
every action you do is it won't be for
the self anymore but that still doesn't
mean that you're going to do things for
other people
do you know the difference well yeah i
think it's like
you can you can have this kind of higher
understanding of what's going on in the
universe on this
you know very kind of cold and detached
disconnected
particulate way where you're just sort
of you know passively observing things
but you know we exist in different
layers and levels there are levels to
who we are
yeah yeah exactly say you're a husband a
father
a friend whatever you know these are all
conditional relations but it's like
our condition ultimate conditional
relation is to the earth
is to this planet into the species that
we are the to the to this world that we
are all a part of to the biosphere to
our ecosystem
not our ego system that is you know this
totally abstract
formless you know it's this
anti-enlightenment to exist in this very
weird
like like it we live in an abstraction
you know we we
people a lot of people you know anybody
who who says spirituality isn't real or
you know that i'm a materialist or
whatever you know we live in this really
weird world where
we live in a world of abstract values
you know we can say it's a scientific
thing that
you know economics dictates you know
that this is the way that things have to
be but that's totally just a nonsense
tradition i mean it's not real it's not
it's not based on anything real
it's based on a belief system that we
have projected onto the world around us
and i think
those people who uh maybe they have
found
maybe they haven't hit enlightenment you
know maybe they've
crowned the to the top of the genres and
they've experienced
the essential final truth of everything
but they're still acting selfishly
or they're still laying around they're
not in their purpose
the road is not over my friend the road
is long from over
and i think for me i didn't i i don't
know i can sit at the table with frank
and with atlas who i think have gone a
lot further
in their introspection than i have but i
in
i mean i'm i'm here you know we're at
the same sort of place we're walking
hand in hand
through this beautiful field of flowers
where what's the roomy quote i know the
uh
uh there's a field but between good and
evil there's a field i'll meet you there
that's a beautiful little quote
but yeah we're here and i anything that
i learned i learned through
feeling the feelings of someone else not
through studying my own brain i mean i'm
obsessed with my own thoughts
and for years i was obsessed with
studying my own thoughts and it just
killed me it just fried me
it was a feedback loop of nonsense and
that's what we were caught in
collectively
and as soon as i i pointed that very
very sensitive microphone that was my
consciousness my awareness away from my
own innards
and pointed it at other people it was
like everything got so much more
beautiful
and not just like nice and good i mean i
i i really started to learn and grow and
and
tune in to like what is my purpose what
is my purpose in relation to other
people
not just to myself not just to my own
bliss
and through doing that i found my bliss
you know which is to is to communicate
this stuff to other people
which is so beautiful to watch frank
transform and his glow up is
the ultimate glow up the frank yang glow
up the body
the mind and heart transformation that
you're at this point where you just want
to share this information
you know like no other spiritual guru or
you know you're not a guru
like i i met a lot of spiritual [ __ ]
you know as you like to call them
yeah that's what exactly i was gonna
mention and they're not they're not
about what you they're really not humble
at all it's called
earth from materialism it's it's yeah
like i said earlier it's hijacking
spirituality for selfish purposes
which makes spirituality really that
after 99 of the people who are into
spirituality are
fall under the umbrella i would say
before you you
completely transcend the self anything
any spiritual practice do
it is going to be in in in a larger
lesser degree about the self um so
that makes spirituality no different
from um
and just to play and just to play on
what frank was just saying there
even though you may
because this has happened to me and many
other people before even though you may
think that you're um
that you're serving other people because
you have this like external facing
mentality which is really important like
what we're describing this is
what you've been saying so important
with meeting basic needs and stuff
but one place that i would agree with
frank where there's like a tremendous
amount of people that fall into this
category right now
is people that are faced outward in
serving people
but are focused even if it's
subconsciously
they're focused on how their image is
going to look in the social sphere
for how then they get their clout and
how they get
more relations and how they get more um
the dopamine this type of thing um
because then they can have
more of of uh it's called the extended
phenotype
in richard dawkins's language and so
they they work on this
on their um their genetic success based
on
social clout and how their individuation
is being portrayed in the sphere
i've seen that so much and actually as
frank just indicated that so much of
what people are hijacking spirituality
as are falling
into that similar category and the only
thing that
holds the only differentiating factor
is not only passion for truth but with
with that is also um passion for
purification
is passion for emptying yourself out of
all of your conditioning and ego and
[ __ ]
so that you can actually serve people
purely
yeah yeah and that's why you have to go
inward
you have to continuously go inward in
order for what you do to when you go
outward to actually be in pure service
and i would say that going after a while
after you
completely go in where you flip yourself
inside out that's why i said
enlightenment is completely selfish and
then
unless until you become completely
selfless and then after
up to that point everything you do is
going to be for the self because you
can't do it nothing
except for the self when you haven't
realized that there is no self right
so whether that's spirituality or or
doing things for the community or for
the environment or playing basketball or
being a ceo but that still doesn't mean
that you can't service others
you know you can't serve other people at
that at that stage you still can it's
important to serve other people at that
stage
still it's it's better to be a selfish
than be a selfish murderer right yes yes
yes
it's better yeah it's better to be a
selfish altruistic pun than a selfless
exactly yeah but after you become
completely selfless it's
the the chance of you murdering a person
would be almost zero unless it's like a
self defense
so that's what i'm saying it's like
after you flip yourself inside out
there's no more distinction between
inside and outside that
the the thing about inside outside is
that in non-duality there is no such
distinctions
you want to think of doing anything for
the self nor will you think of any to do
anything for the for the other people
you just do
things and whatever you do would be pure
regardless
even if it's just playing video game
but the thing is that the thing is the
tricky part is like after
that realization this that you don't
know what you're to do
yeah i think that's the really tricky
thing about the that's the really tricky
thing about enlightenment it's like
you don't know where you're going
afterwards this is this is the place
where
and that's right that's right you could
say that
a lot of the organizations that gather
people together that have awakened
and to work on uh a collective objective
like igniting global
awakening like what we're doing with
vincent umasaro and the
uh no limit society that i that that
seems to be
one of the best ways to sort of um
to take what you said is this we don't
know what will happen
to uh we can actually create like these
landing strips
for people as they awaken and then we
can help them integrate their awakening
we can help with um with turning people
in uh more and more towards pure service
as they've went in
until that duality is transcended but
that's that's great
because because it is very important to
have a community and have
home um as you go through this process
of
even physically when you become aware of
the oneness of the planet that in itself
is mind-blowing
when you begin understanding that your
life is interdependent on trees and
phytoplankton photosynthesizing oxygen
for you
um because you when you take that truth
to people
that um don't understand that oneness
aspect to reality um
uh they can sometimes feel contracted
because they they don't necessarily feel
that it's almost like you can start
getting a little bit of porosity
of the self begins feeling some oneness
porosity
they begin feeling perforated almost
based on physicalism
to start a lot of the time they start
feeling oneness more in a physicalism
sense on a planetary level
at least a star yeah it's like they're
on mali or something you know they're
not really
tuned in and connected to really it's
like connecting to
our sense of our self beyond
individualism and i think that's
that's kind of been the prevailing uh
view
is in the spiritual community it's like
okay we need to purify the individual
and then collective change will come out
as a result of the individual changing
and that's sort of where i've grown to
to really differ i mean maybe
it's it's because i'm at a point in
myself where
uh i feel like i
i don't know maybe i'm qualified to
to reckon with reality who reckon with
this crazy world
from a spiritual perspective and you
know like like when you pulled up that
page on class consciousness karl marx
came up and i think a lot of people
i feel like asserting this because a lot
of people have become
identified with these belief systems you
know and that's the way that they
perceive you know the struggle of the
system is through this dogma of
someone else's view purview and i think
karl marx is that's true
you're you're right capitalism yeah
people people
and i don't know i'm mostly true these
days and then these circles of
historicals and activists and the people
who are systems thinkers or
economists or political ideologies
are have ideologies are pathologized
everywhere in culture everywhere
creating lots of separation
a lot of separation people try to
pinpoint me to an ideology or when i
talk the way that i do they say oh
you're a communist or oh you're a
socialist or you're an anarchist
and it's it's uh what what are you
what's your thing and it's like well
really it's a spiritual perspective it's
like a
common sense perspective that what we're
doing is wrong and
unsustainable and destructive and
it for me it's like it is a place it
does come from a place of intuition
i don't i feel like that's a tricky
thing to sort of uh
suggest to people because you know the
nazis felt intuitively right about what
they were doing or you know
someone in the kkk who is motivated
maybe by a love for his daughter because
he has a wrongful belief about
you know a wrongful racist belief that
is you know
maybe he feels that he is intuitively in
the right position and is not
continually analyzing that in any sort
of um
rigor without with rigor you know there
is no there is no lens between
you know or latency between his feeling
and his action and i think it
it's very tricky to traverse these
states and to go from like this
you know lou spiritual perspective that
often can disconnect people from
their connection to systems and to
politics and through the everyday
reality
of our collective shared humanity and
then there's the other side of that
where
someone is so lost in the system's
approach or in the ideology or in
they're only doing that that they become
in their own way
just another reactive mechanism like a
lot of marxists i know
are just totally reactive they're a
reaction to a reaction to a reaction
they're not
really coming from an organic place of
really questioning
every single thought that comes to their
head and everything in their world and i
it's very hard to prescribe changes like
that but i think to sort of boil this
on endless tangent that will only be
broken up momentarily
and added with another tangent that we
need to shift from that
change the person to change the world i
think the people who are changed on that
personal level
through the miracles of suffering and
the grace of other people and the love
that has helped them get there like i am
only alive right now
because of love i didn't believe my own
life was worth saving and
you know that's the only reason that i
feel that the world is
changeable that can be that climate
catastrophe can be changed today and
averted because
my own life which i didn't believe in at
all was saved
by love by the love of other people we
need to shift to a point where the
people
at that place you know stop preaching a
doctrine of
oh save yourself and then you can be
like me or whatever we need to work
together
to attack these systems or grab these
systems
catch the identifying mechanism of you
know the human persona
which is this you know the ego system of
capitalism of
trade and business and economics the
the words that the politics that make
our world go around we need to take
those
those back from these people who are
just reactions of reactions of reactions
and work to intelligently program them
to meet everyone's needs and get
everyone
to a better place so it's a collective
awakening that's that's the title of
this episode that's really what i feel
like is important to talk about in my
heart even though i love just
diving into the you know the beautiful
poetry of reality of of
spirituality okay take take an example
if you've ever seen mycorrhizal networks
how
fungi works underground fungi works
underground in a two-way resource
exchange with 95
of plants it's unbelievable how it works
and so
here's the thing is that it works in a
decentralized way fungi works in a
decentralized way
class consciousness and having a
this everything based on capitalism and
wealth
and having contracting perspectives if
again if we go through this not having
basic needs met where i'm working 80
hours a week
i have no time to turn inward and
understand metacognition whatsoever
what's going to happen is that your lens
of perception is going to get contracted
and contracted and contracted
the scripts are going to pathologize
your life
and you're going to more and more be fed
in the data streams
that make you more and more of a slave
to that specific
class consciousness that specific lens
whether you're successful or
poor you know and yes yes and the way to
break
out of that in many ways is these tiny
little nudges that can be made for
people of course
architectural systems which we'll talk
about in a moment that biomimic
mycorrhizal networks and fungi but
yeah yeah talk dirty to me exactly
because that that's
that's ultimately the big picture thing
is like transcending
a lot of the existing centralized
infrastructures that contract people's
consciousness
and transcending that to decentralized
liberated architectures that enable
people to pursue
higher states of consciousness in
essence pause
pause i just want to say that i love you
both very much
i love you i love you both too atlas
and zach i love you guys
yeah this is this uh this is our second
conversation
and i love that i love meeting someone
and just meeting them at the heart level
you know the totality that
you know the like this is humanity you
know it's it's not
this is our most efficient way of of
cogitating is
this weird evolution that we do which
isn't like create tools and throw things
and use our thumbs
it's to like merge our consciousness
with somebody else and we in our brains
grow in the process
so we're like this weird three-headed
wonderful
three-headed weirdo right now you know
oscillating into war towards some great
awakening or some great insight
so yeah i have a little input of what
you just said
yes go ahead um i think
i think awakening is going beyond right
and wrong because
right right right now there is still a
duality in what you're saying zach that
this thing is right and then that thing
is wrong and i think that's where
actually the conflict comes from
is that a certain group of people
thinking their idea is
right and the other group think it's
wrong and for me awakening is waking up
both
out of both of these paradigms out of
both out of the both of the green
paradigm
the environmental product and the
capitalist paradigm because right now
those two paradigms are
what's causing the conflicts in each of
those paradigms they're thinking they're
right
well but if if the yeah i mean
isn't that just the leap system is that
what
isn't it just a belief system that um
hurting the plan is wrong
yes so frank when so frank when so like
here's here's a here's a decent way to
put that that might that might provide
inside so we're gonna so we're going to
transcend
this this is a very good point this is a
very good point
there's one set of centralized archaic
infrastructures that exist right now
that promulgate separation
then there's this new envisioned set of
architectures that are more around
decentralization that biomimic fungal
networks
that are more about enabling they're
they are they're way older they're
actually this set of
is actually a billion years old up here
and so the billion-year-old intelligence
like fungi
is what we're aiming to to architect
next and so what we're saying is that
this to is not their book
so in the most non-dual perspective
they're
we transcend this completely um
in the dualistic concessionary
perspective that we can hold
simultaneously
we see that these biomimic fungal
networks
are by far where we need to build our
civilization moving forward
um to to increase and accelerate
planetary awakening
and so you can hold non-duality where
you collapse this
and also duality at the same time where
there's something to build towards
that's better i read an interesting
thing about power struggles
uh the other day that uh often in
struggles of power where there's
asymmetry
the the force that's in power
isn't even aware that there is an
alternative you know and and
i'm sure that the forces in power are
acutely aware that there is an
alternative
and they feel in their logic that these
people are jealous of our success
or you know if they have their way then
our whole mechanism which is
to them right because i don't believe
that
people are into anyone out there is
intentionally destroying the earth
they're
they're just literally mentally ill in a
cultural delusion and i think
i think that i i don't really i don't
know
engaging in like is it is there a point
or is it better for the world to die or
the world to live like if an asteroid
crashed into the earth tomorrow and blew
it up
that wouldn't be immoral that wouldn't
be wrong or even inefficient that would
kind of be the will of the universe you
know and if humans destroy the earth
i suppose that's the will of the
universe but i don't believe that that's
going to happen
i don't i it will happen
i love your podcast by the way you
should link uh his podcast to the the
video
this will be the link in the bio yeah
the speech that you gave at the end was
very motivating for me i liked it i gave
me goosebumps
you've been really optimistic about um
climate change
the the park has to deal with your
friends about climate change at the end
you gave this whole speech about how
you're optimistic
even though the whole thing is [ __ ] up
so i i like that anyway i just want to
mention that
i mean yeah that's i i think i said it
better in that speech than i could here
i mean it
because it was really presented with
like okay the earth is going to die if
we don't continue doing this
my dear friend allen who's a a brilliant
environmentalist who's a brilliant
atheist
by the way who i love very much you know
laid it out that like this is what's
happening
this is what's going to happen if we
don't radically radically change
that all life on earth is essentially
going as we know it
because it'll still be the rhizomel
micro rhizomal fungi will still uh
they'll inherit the earth but we and you
know complex life forms
on down to anything about as complex as
a chicken is gonna be
you know dunzo so that's that's it that
you know and
we can we could go down a deep rabbit
hole of saying you know
is one better than the other but it's
not like it's one belief system fighting
another
it's one belief system fighting the
inherent selflessness of life
existing growing coexisting coagulating
coming together
and intensifying you know cells forming
and
intensifying that are based off of uh
you know some
some aloof process of archetypal
generation of meaning
a purpose that it the universe is not
even if if it is
an illusion and it is if it's a
simulation and it is
we watch movies and they give us meaning
in our lives and i think that's what our
existence is in this world that
ultimately
we are creating meaning on a deep level
we we may be a simulation but it's there
is a viewer there is a final observer
that the whole
world in itself is watching itself and
i'm not sure if there are formless
beings
you know with personalities and
intelligences
like the the bhagavad-gita says and the
vedas say that there are personalities
guiding the universe on an archetypal
sort of way they're not just
blind forces of science of you know uh
you know like the fibonacci sequence or
you know
mathematics guiding the universe and i
think that is a manifestation of
a kind of god a kind of you know higher
order intelligence and it that's what
all of reality is
but really we exist and life is precious
it's precious because it just [ __ ] is
it doesn't need to be vindicated any
more than that
and what i am talking about what i feel
like advocating for
is not a shift from one belief system to
another but it's a shift away from the
artificial narrative that we have
implanted on reality this is what
reality is this is what life is this is
what humanity is this is what we got to
do
we got to be successful we got to
convert every living thing into dead
profit you know it's shifting out of
that
it's ending this nightmare and basically
lapsing back into this collective
not just collective awakening doesn't
just mean every person individually
achieves enlightenment and then they can
play video games and be enlightened it's
it's a deeper
level of evolution it's a true evolution
of our consciousness
to the point where we are raising up out
of all of these wheels of reactivity and
duality
and all these narratives fighting
narratives marxism versus capitalism
it's an end all of that and it's racing
and saying okay
we're going to connect with our
intuitive true sense of who we are
as collaborative intuitive creatures
that work together to solve problems
we're going to raise us up
out of scarcity which is manufactured
truly we manufacture scarcity we
we grow enough food to feed 10 billion
humans and there's a human dies of
starvation every six seconds
one two three four five six dead person
dead human life pointless pointless loss
we
that person could be einstein you know
that person could
drastically improve the quality of life
for all of us that all of our our
you know mindless distractions that keep
us from actually pondering
and connecting with and substantiating
materially and spiritually what is going
on
from achieving that can i challenge you
on that again
sure that's why we're here buddy
isn't the idea of escaping the ego into
the collective universal consciousness
uh just another idea yeah it's really
actually just a scheme from to make
money i just try no
no i'm not i'm not going i'm not even
going there i'm saying that's just i'm
riffing on you
are you what'd you say again i'm saying
the move from
collective the move from the egoistic
mind to the universal mind consciousness
you're saying that's the meaning of of
existence and i'm challenging you on
that one i'm saying that's just another
idea
well ultimately yeah whatever happens
happens and we are
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
now it's important to challenge what you
just said
um so
so um
is it is it not is it not
generally clear that
um this expression of infinity
this universe um
has within it a
a cosmological phenomenon that
is that appears like consciousness
awakening to recognizing
its nature
um i i would say they're they're like we
talked about the last episode there
isn't
there is some kind of knowing there's an
experience going on for sure but
anything that that is said with about
that experience including that is
consciousness or that it's our it's our
duties or is our
it's the meaning of life to return to
that source
it becomes another belief after a while
i'm not i'm not doubting that there is
something going on here
okay okay okay hold on hold on hold on
another way to another way to say that
would be that
um if if you or i
marlow onward if we undergo a process
of let's say um uh
uniting with the undercurrent of
existence
um a very general
product of that is to is to serve
as well as we can um other uh
pieces of life um awakening to the very
undercurrent of existence
so it that that seems to be at least
in this expression of infinity what is
happening
we're not talking about consciousness
we're not talking we're no we're not
talking about
just more like um there is what appears
to be
somebody that um had a more contracted
energy
and that now has a much more infinite
free
energy and that in in essence what is
happening is these pieces of life
are going from that to
does does that not appear to be how this
is architected
it's an expression of efficiency it's
not just this is right and morally right
or wrong
it's it's it's something that is
essentially parasitic
and addictive that is that is driving
humanity
to look away from you know i i hesitate
to say like it's true potential or for
what is but it
it's a distractive destructive addictive
force
that will snuff out all of life on this
earth and the ability and potential for
consciousness
to continue to grow and expand and swell
and you know this earth itself
took billions and hun you know billions
of years to form
life took billions of years to form you
know intelligent life that can coagitate
on the form that we can
although i think you know animals can
dolphins can dogs can
they have an awareness of themselves
birds can look at themselves in the
mirror
i mean our views of what of what is
conscious are very very limited there's
a
i was reading in the shaiva the shaiva
tradition the shiva oracles were
they've actually predated the hindu and
the vedic vedic
and the buddhists they're like the
wellspring the sea kind of secret seed
uh spiritual practice and tradition they
were they were saying that the
everything in existence is conscious you
know down to a rock a rock
it may have a small pers amount of
consciousness as compared to something
like a human or a dolphin or whatever
but everything is conscious everything
exists and is
i think gravitating towards something
greater something
there is an evolution going on it isn't
just particles bumping into each other
randomly you know forming for a little
while
i mean that's all that's also part of
the evolution
we we evolved to get to this moment you
know you
i atlas we did and i think it's
it's not like we're switching a belief
system for another belief system
it's just kind of shaking off the weight
of of an addiction of a delusion of an
attachment like you have an attachment
to anything else you know
likes like people who are still stuck at
their attachment as a man or
a human or uh you know any of these
things that we attach ourselves to that
keeps us from progressing
even somebody's attachment to themselves
as a guru like oh i've figured it out
i've reached enlightenment that's a
narrative that's keeping somebody from
achieving
what from just getting there from
realizing something deeper about reality
or about themselves
and i think all of these things are just
fundamentally keeping us from realizing
that
alone and individually you know
individually and together
and i think that there is something that
it's only a dream it's never been seen
or done before maybe it has
thousands of years ago in human history
that we were we lived in this perfect
one this is perfect unity
and we were able to you know think on
greater levels than we are today
but we're getting to the point where we
can actually connect our consciousness
not just like through the internet not
through some drilling some chip in our
head
but by just being aware of each other's
existence being aware of our own
thoughts our own consciousness and the
consciousness of others
that's going to take us to a place we've
never seen before that you haven't seen
before that
that none of us has experienced before
so right now i'm looking i have a
visualization of like three different
i don't want to say ideology but three
different ways of
experience in the world we have the
capitalistic uh perspective and then we
have the
environmental perspective and then we
have the clinical spiritual perspective
and they're to me they're all
co-dependent rising they they are
co-creating each other
they need each other and to me they're
all the same
and from the perspective of that space
which gives rise to
all three systems
it's hard to comprehend this whole thing
about
evolution of um i i think like you said
everything is evolving in a sense but
nothing is
moving so the two levels are operating
simultaneously it's like
inevitably we're involved in that's why
i keep telling people where involving
where you know we're going somewhere but
at the same time the consciousness
cannot evolve because consciousness
doesn't have levels
so there's an evolution in levels of the
mind and levels of thinking
before you get to the non-dual state of
consciousness
so that's what we're doing as a
collective thing
is that we're changing our mind and
belief system so that we can
break out of it so it's not like it's
not like consciousness
is evolving because consciousness
doesn't evolve consciousness the
universe is just
it's just the way it is there's no
levels to the thing
all levels still belongs to the dream
state into the mind but you have to go
through levels you have to perceive the
level understand that there is a level
to the mind
before you can deconstruct the mind and
enter that state where there is no
levels
so so apparently at the same time there
isn't everything is happening
yeah nothing's happening and that's the
simultaneity
which is such an important
get down with that that you know time as
we perceive it is a
totally linear thing you know we are we
are witnessing this
like you know one frame or we're
witnessing it as successive frames but
when you're in the editor you can go
backward you know that's a good one from
the true perspective you can go in any
direction
you know and i think a lot of people get
stuck in a moral real quick and a lot of
people get stuck in a moralistic
sort of judgment of say the capitalistic
perspective or this
the you know the individual perspective
when in reality
it is an aspect of evolution that we
have to say okay this wasn't just a
total deviation for no reason
this was to learn a lesson you know the
reason we separate
from one or from zero to one and then to
two and
and on is basically to learn like okay
we wanna get back to zero i've been
writing this crazy fantasy
sci-fi fantasy novel about all of human
history and consciousness and of course
frankie yang is a character and he plays
a shape-shifting
uh buddha going around telling people
that they're everything they believe is
an illusion and then like hey
my reality reality's not an illusion
it's real and then try to kick his ass
and he's like he's like a super strong
shape-shifter it's great it's going to
be it's going to break me
it's going to break narratives the
characters are
going to be a series of films someday
the characters basically get to the
point where they all ascend
they they defeat the dragon and they
save the world and you know and then
they're like okay but this isn't it
they keep going and eventually they go
to the realm of gods of the archetypes
that make all this happen and they're
these tiny little beings watching this
war of the gods play out where this
errant god this sort of lucifer this
satan this this ego you know the
individual the
ego is you know it's a collective
thought dream of a
a disordered state of the human ego that
we have projected onto all of society
and said this is it this is the the
thing the truth
and that's capitalism that's the you
know endlessly expanding growth
cancerous growth model of capitalism but
so it's like basically
this god this force uh kills all of the
other gods and radically reduces them
down to one
and from one zero and that's the birth
of the universe so it's like
we basically went so astray in ourselves
in this capitalistic system in this
point where we've pushed our earth to
the point where it's about to die
our mother is on her deathbed is
rattling with a
cough and she has to shake us off to
continue living
and i think that happened so we could
learn that's not the way
that we don't do that again and when we
are learning this it's a simulation
that all of consciousness itself is
learning through us whether we
will in a linear fashion experience that
we probably won't you know but it's
that's why we're going through it to
create
meaning and i think you could say that's
an arbitrary term or that's just a
belief system that's my belief
i still have beliefs you know maybe i
just haven't
sat under a tree long enough but i
believe that
i believe because it it it's not like
something
that's true it's like this is my mother
the whole purpose of my existence that's
and i'm not free
to pursue what would it what would it be
like if you did
empty yourself of all beliefs just
curious [ __ ] rad
i'd probably just be better at what i'm
doing i don't know maybe yeah that's
what
maybe i would just realize that the
earth isn't worth saving and i just play
video games
that is such a common by the way guess
what guess what
by the way guess guess what in guess
what is creating that thought
the conditioning that doesn't want to
dissolve no it's a joke it's a joke
honestly you tell me that all the time
because i'm
my podcast moneyless society it's in
it's about all of this it's about
you know collective systems change it's
in its own way it's a spirit i consider
it a spiritual work because
to do spiritual work i have to wake down
in frank's beautiful term
to understand the way that this system
works that's keeping people from
realizing that
and the central you know core you know
fetishes tokenistic belief system that
keeps us there
this magical implement this you know
parasitic adaptation this technology
that has convinced the human species to
forego all its symbiotic relationships
for this one thing that makes it so i
don't need anyone and that's money
people can't do that that just breaks
their brain to think that we could live
without money even though we did for
the you know the vast majority of human
existence people say if we take that out
of the way or if we end
society's problems or if we meet
everybody's needs
there'll be no point there'll be no why
would we wake up in the morning why
would we do anything
what you know what will be the point of
that and i think that's the silliest
thing in the entire world that's the
most privileged position imaginable it's
like
oh we end suffering you know as we not
we'll always suffer
life will always be a crazy dangerous
you know
insane adventure you know
i'm not afraid of that i i i i'm excited
for it
if we go if we if we scrub this video
back
like uh three minutes or what not where
you just said
that um if you emptied out those last
bits of conditioning and beliefs you
would be
better at what oh no
okay so now wait let's let's just stay
with this for a moment
so what's holding you back then
from emptying out those last bits of
conditioning and beliefs that would make
you
better at being in pure service to
exactly what you're blueprinted for and
what you're already doing
well it's the it's the rigor and the
discipline to you know
to go through it it's it's not fear it's
it's time
and uh it's intention and it's okay wait
what do you think what do you think the
rigor and discipline
is to deconstruct that last bit of
conditioning what
would what do you think that that
process is
well it's spending it a lot of time it's
like you know
going to the gym and bulking up like our
our
guru frank as you know it's uh
it's it's going through the process of
of the and the discipline of hitting
those genres you know
i don't know i generally do feel empty
it's interesting like some a friend was
asking me like you know
what's on you what are you thinking
about what's on your mind i asked i
asked a girl that the other day
what are you thinking about she gave me
a really specific thing she said what
are you thinking about i said nothing
nothing at all i can't conjure a thought
i mean my mind is
generating things but i can't make it
think for me i
i don't know it's very interesting like
talking to people through a lot of this
stuff
that i i mean i've taken ayahuasca and
you know and and i've
i've just gone through so much profound
suffering so many dark
nights of the soul i don't i'm sure
there are there are
you know there's conditioning left to
undo and i mean i'm a white man you know
i grew up entitled and rich and
or you know fairly well off and all that
rich by anybody in the world standards
you know
most of the people in the world living
on two dollars a day yeah i grew up rich
so there's tons to dismantle there's
always more to dismantle there's always
more to to dig
out of ourselves and i i encourage
and i encourage anyone and everyone i
encourage myself and i need to do that
it's a path that i will take it's an
eventuality it's not something i might
do or
i'm on the fence about it's it's an
adventure i will go on when i'm called
to it
but right now this is this is the the
fruition of
the bhakti yoga or is it bhakti yoga
devotional yoga
you know this yoga this service this
i've been holding this pose
for a long time and and i'm about to get
that kundalini bust
you know of making things change because
that's it that's what i'm here to do
and i will always you know strive to
improve and grow
and to dismantle to get there to get
there better
what else i can say yeah
when when everything is meaningless that
means everything is meaningful right
you can't have a duality you're not
meaningless and what's meaningful
reality is neither
one nor the many you you know what i've
been
saying is uh purposeful purposeful
meaninglessness
absurdity um what about
um what about diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of the infinite
that's a good one and the one there's
neither
one of the many but both they exist
simultaneously yes and
you know why i point out the whole thing
about universal consciousness is being
another belief
is that that's why you said earlier
about how a lot of spiritual people
they're they're kind of trapped in that
box right
of just falling back into the absolute
transcendence
and we're just talking about the same
thing earlier on the previous podcast
about how
there are really three stages first you
have the normal world that the world
through the lens of the separates of the
ego world the second you have the
spiritual world
the world through the the absolute
transcendence the world through the god
my whatever
and all the mystical traditions that's
their peak point is that unity total
unity
and then there's a third level which is
coming down from the absolute
transcendence and uniting nirvana with
samsara
that's the quote-unquote actual world
and i tell people that if you want to
experience the actual world watch the
animal planet or watch our planet
you know that that dependency of the
organism is that the naturalness the
natural state it's not just one or the
many it's not just god consciousness or
it's not just the animal the ego
it's everything is just co-dependent
arising through links of conditions
and causes and that to me feels more
like the true nature of our state than
say kundalini explosions or like angels
or gods or even fractal dmt trip
or capitalism or even
you know you know you know selfish
pursues an egoistic maniac
a depiction of of of human beings
i like wolf of war neither of those are
the natural state but both of them are
at the same time
yeah it's about watching watching
strangers on on a train you know
that's beautiful to me a friend of mine
just said this i got this
beautiful thing on film he was just like
that's the most amazing thing to me
that's the thing i'm going to miss the
most when i'm dead it's not my mom
it's not my lover it's just random
interactions with human beings it's just
being a human
to put one more you know just say one
more thing about me what i'm doing why i
feel called to do this
it's not because it's moral it's not
because you know i have an
argument or because i surveyed a one
belief system against another it's just
because i don't have a choice i do it
because it is natural
it is my it is my natural state to do
this
and all my life has spent
you know going through this adventure
you're talking about those three stages
you know
it's like uh the book that bloom blew my
mind was the hero's journey or they're
here with a thousand faces by joseph
campbell
that was like we're all on an adventure
we're all on this journey
and there's the ordinary world and then
there's there's the fantastical world
dreams and fairies and monsters and
treasures and that world exists
that world exists in your mind and it
exists in the world outside of that if
you step out of
what you accept to be the truth of
reality you can find that world
but that and most hollywood movies are
actually based on that structure
but the way they get it wrong is that it
ends with the character
you know getting that kundalini bust
they get their own
boon but it ends when you bring the boon
back to the ordinary world and you give
it to them and you share it you share it
with them
and it becomes a shared experience that
that's why you go crazy
that's why you go into the wilderness
and take on the devil which is you
which is you all the gods all the
monsters are you their consciousness
they're the self
but you go through that stuff to find
that sacred treasure that life-giving
water
to bring it back to the world
that's it and that's beautiful to me and
it's an insane thing it's not rational
at all
it's it's rational in the way that uh a
peregrine falcon stooping
and flying 200 miles an hour down
from the sky to grab a smaller bird and
eat it you know
that's not a rational thing you just
it's instinct
it's great it feels great do it dive in
if you
if you can find that water of the heart
dive the [ __ ] in
and follow that passion until you're not
moving anymore on your own volition
and your only choice is even choosing a
piece of pizza it's like what do i want
on that
oh i could say i have the choice to
choose my toppings i don't have a choice
i'm going to get the burrata you know
it's the only
it's the only one the hero's journey
seems to be one of the best ways to
help people shift from the existing
scripts
into um more
uh sovereignty and freedom and
actualization
and planetary prosperity so that's a
great archetype it's a
critical one and just to also touch on
um what we've been talking about
regarding fungi
and what frank just mentioned a moment
ago as well
where there there does seem to be a
um a pretty fascinating um
you're kind of you're kind of birthed in
as a as a person and then you're like
okay how do i transcend this and then
you merge with god
which you were the whole time all the
whole time um and then
and then after that um there's no
distinction
uh between what is mundane worldly stuff
and what is the transcendent nirvanic
stuff and then and then that
meeting point that meeting point
is what the fungal networks are
basically trying to say
um and yeah and then that's really where
i've gotten
[ __ ] um in the last couple of like
especially like weeks um
is that um what they're
telling us which is a is
it's a it's a more than one billion year
old intelligence
which by the way we come from 650
million years ago
the animal split from fungal lineage
so animals are descendants of fungi
so when frank talks about animal planet
and the earth and the natural state um
it's all a dependent origination it's
all
infinity [ __ ] itself with endless
amounts of
webs of causes in it's beautiful like
one of the most important messages that
i got from fungi
about like three months ago or something
like that was that
it went something like this it was like
eons
[ __ ] eons [ __ ]
eons [ __ ] and what it was saying was
that
it took eons [ __ ] for you to have the
exact
experiences for you to have the exact
movie
that you're having right now eons [ __ ]
endless infinite dependent
webs for you to have this experience
and that melted the [ __ ] out of me
um and that's what we are
that's that's what we are and um
and so that's why when people talk about
um this
centerless uh non-dual
very decentralized universalized cosmic
octopus
as as frank says where each of us are
tentacles
um that uh the
the the
there's no words it's kind of like
it's kind of like this it's kind of like
each of us is a tentacle but at the same
time we're also the originator of all
the tentacles
so like when i hear sensations outside
right now when i look at the clouds or
when i
hear the cars driving by when i look at
you guys i'm experiencing everything as
just webs just connected like physically
connected to everything
so it does literally feels like every
single sensation is like a tentacle
of tentacle of tentacle right and this
whole field is absolutely connected
there's just the body of the cosmic
cosmo
the the cosmic oxide but the same time
this cosmic octopus
there is just a manifestation there's
just a sensation there's no there's no
center point to this octopus
you know i mean so it's not like frank
the octopus having tentacles
it's that frank here this thing this
like
this thing here is just part of the it's
just one tentacle
right and there's no central tentacle
because everything is
have because nothing non ten no
tentacles can exist
by itself hasn't it existed apart from
those relations
alan can you look up uh it's called
indra's net it's describing this exactly
and i think it's from tibetan buddhism
and it's
so good it's basically that there's a
crystal lattice a web
of everything and um the dangerous
jewels
and just pearls oh it's so beautiful
that there's a web of life that life is
every single
by the way look at what the first it's a
metaphor
used to illustrate sunyata emptiness
and then also dependent origination
essentially i hope i don't mess this up
because it's such a it's like the most
beautiful metaphor for everything that
i've ever heard that
there's a net a web of it's all
connected at this point at all these
uh you know vertices these points and
every point is connected to every other
point
but it sounds like anything itself every
single point is yeah
so every moment that has ever come to
pass in this web of
not just you know all of our
associations our lives our dreams
our you know best moments or worst
moments they're all tethered in this
wonderful way
that if you really look at it and i was
talking about this today with
you know the ways that filmmaking or
bringing a camera out changes reality
that to look at to look at each moment
you can see the light shine through the
crystal beads and but oh yeah
point a camera at somebody else and ask
them their story
as if it is a story you know in a way of
showing other people
their hero's journey because people walk
through this world most of them they
don't think they have a story
they don't think that there's a a a
trajectory of their lives they just kind
of think it's just random that
this happened then this happened and
then this happened oh and then that
happened but really when you get people
talking about it and you ask the right
questions
you can really show somebody that oh i
love this moment
this moment that i thought was
meaningless or that i thought was the
worst moment of my life and this is the
most consistent thing i realized
in studying stories and looking at my
own story and i've been obsessed with my
own story
you know forever and seeing that there's
a story in this life and i can't waste
this life
on the mundane moments i can't i have to
leave the ordinary world not stay here
in it
that when you realize that the worst
moments in your life the most
gutless catastrophes that busted
everything open and ripped you apart
and and you know poured acid down into
the most sensitive
aspect of you that moment is the moment
that led you to awakening to
enlightenment to
the to a beautiful sunset or to just a
moment of calm when it was all over and
that's this moment we're in
as a species as a collective that our
earth is
on fire and is flooding and you've got
billionaires flying around in space
taking selfies while it's happening
and you got human beings digging in a
garbage can for food
while that's happening this the
indignity of this all seems
[ __ ] insane if you don't see that
there's a story to it that there's an
evolution going on
that all of this happens for a reason
and maybe that reason is just you know
to bring things back to the heat death
of the universe and you know the
undoing of the big bang or whatever the
beginning moment is that or that
that independent origination where
nothing became somethingness
i i don't think that's true i think that
we we are going through this so we can
learn from it so we can learn better
and so our consciousness or
consciousness altogether
i can't substantiate that to say that
consciousness can evolve
but everything else evolves why can't
everything why can't everythingness
evolve
or even nothingness can nothingness not
learn can nothingness not grow
everything else does nothing else does
we aren't learning nothing nothing is
changing everything is changing
i'm getting confused i need to meditate
more
wait can you pull up that picture again
thanks for the
um telling us about the intro what's it
called
interesting interesting yeah there's one
picture that i like thank you
thank you for calling that up it's such
a good one
that's one particular one that i really
like can we see it again
there's one with just a nap but there's
no notes that one's really
the there's one with that one i think
that one right there yeah that one no
the one
not that one the one to the left of that
that one that one is pretty good because
it's just just a net there's no
there's no notes like there's no there's
no particles in between those
those connections click it
it's really hard it's it's almost
impossible to to illustrate this this is
so complex but
see how there's there's really no like
there's no
not even that there's no like cir
there's not like balls in between those
nets in a sense
right some of the other pictures have
like a big ball but that's the thing you
try to get the construct
there's no balls there's just the
relations this is the connections
the yeah
there's no balls there's only
relations yeah yeah there's no balls but
speaking of balls
i hate this but i have to pee i was
going to say frank if you want to read
your basketball post
speaking of balls i was gonna i was
going to say something about time
because you said something
about how movies everything is existing
simultaneously
yeah same thing with the like ultimate
ultimately
go pee bro frank talk do your do your
basketball thing
because you were you were hot to try
let's do that later at some point at
some point we will yeah yeah we'll see
in a bit
so whatever what he said about the film
uh everything is this simultaneously
um i think that links only exists on the
relative level of
spatial dimension of space and time as
well because
ultimately there's no process ultimately
everything is spontaneous and
simultaneously arising
oh we're pausing i i just made your
screen big
oh okay um yeah so that would lead to
the basketball post because uh
the thing about decentralization in
basketball uh let me go peep let me go
to them
i'll keep people occupied for a moment
love you guys
thanks for tuning in fam
super appreciate you
and super appreciate your your comments
thank you we'll
hope to answer your questions
that you have
i am back broth okay frank you keep
people occupied
we've we have an audience question that
i feel like
it would be good for you for you to
answer as well
um so i'm gonna go use the bathroom
and marlo's back so i'm gonna i'm gonna
go use the bathroom quick
um you guys chat let's we'll get to this
audience question
um maybe after i come back or
whenever with the basketball stuff blah
blah blah
be right back i was just i was just
laughing
in the as i was taking my leak
performing my human function
engaging in this do this this
nonsensical dualistic web
of balls and balls uh i was just
laughing how you and
atlas were talking about you were like
bro
you haven't awakened would you haven't
died oh bro bro you got to do it you
were like
you were like like big brothers that
were like oh dude you've never
drank before bro you got a drink dude oh
you got to have this it's great
i just love how innocent and sincere and
just and just
exhilarated you are about you know
experiences like that and i just i just
love your zeal
i'm just going to give them 30 seconds
here and just appreciate you frank
because
you're one of my very favorite life
forms death forms nothingness forms
formless emptinesses because you have
this insatiable zeal and curiosity
that is like such a miraculous thing and
so many people just lack they're not
curious they're not interested in their
world
they don't want to know anything they
just want to if anything they want to
dull it like with alcohol you know
well i think what i'm doing is kind of
similar to what you're doing it's just
in a different way um yeah
so whatever you said could be directed
to yourself that's the whole point right
we're we're
directing it all at the self yeah
because um
when you ask people what they do after
realization like we said like different
people do different things you can play
basketball
you can be a ceo you can like be a porn
star you can
be environmentalist um
i guess the point is afterwards is you
just do
what i think the program that you were
running before
is important because whatever program
they're wanting before will
probably most likely keep running itself
in a more efficient way because without
the doer
without the agency in the center it's
it's like it's like we talked about
earlier like
when you when you hear a sound before
awakening before non-duality is the if
you hear the sound there's a delay
right there's you and the sound there's
a delay there's the delay between all
the sensations
yeah there's a delay between the seer
and the scene but after you deconstruct
the center point
there's just the scene and hearing
that's just the hearing in thinking
there's just
thinking it's not like you can't think
it's not you can't you have to be in the
space of no thought it's not like that
it's like when you think
it's not you thinking it's thought just
just and there's no thinker there's only
thoughts
and thoughts your thoughts thoughts
actually become a lot more
clean and efficient and you have better
thoughts when there is no thinking of
filtering the thoughts
because i think it's just an
afterthought to lay over it right it's
all
interesting i i don't know i don't know
if maybe i'm just ignorant or
but that's really kind of how it when
you describe it that's how it feels in
my head
you know it yeah that's right it feels
it feels great it feels empty but
there's
i read that beautiful quote by uh
bruce lee you know be like water i think
it's one of the most beautiful things
anyone has ever said i mean i don't i
don't know that it
originated with him lauza
i love his expansion of it where he's
just talking about like water can crash
you know water can
drip it he said he said it well yeah it
was a lot of suit
all right yeah i gotta reread the towel
the dow yeah
the shape of whatever container you're
in you know and i think that's kind of
one of the core principles of the
insecurity
of our you know kind of western
materialistic capitalistic whatever
society
wait before before i lose this this is i
think this is a very important point
um frank is
is the analogy to continue that
the the appearances
that are happening on the screen
the appearances that happen on the
screen the screen is for
no one and then the screen and the
appearances are the same
that there's no differentiation between
them but and then the appearances are
happening for no one
yeah yeah so basically that that's why i
was telling him earlier about how like
he's doing what he's doing i'm doing
what i'm doing and
then afterwards after realization the
programming can continue
but without the doer without the agent
it would be a lot quicker a lot more
spontaneous and a lot
more efficient and whatever it is that
you're doing
right so
so in a sense there's no there's not
even a container to contain the water
what i'm saying about that quote is that
he it's like our attitude our deeply
embedded individualistic attitude that
is based in insecurity
in scarcity and debt and war and all
these
false things is to wherever you go you
assert yourself
you say this is me this is my place you
project outward
what you think you are onto reality in
this in this way that is so insecure
that you know armies in the world right
now are going into other countries
like cuba they're threatening to do this
to cuba they want to smash cuba
into the shape of what we think the
united states thinks
it's supposed to be which is it you know
instead of saying instead of allowing
instead of going into a room
and and feeling that room not feeling a
separation
you know going into that room and just
effortlessly being in that space and i
think i feel like that
fluidity for me came from hitchhiking
more than anything of
traveling around and realizing like okay
i go from place to place
i don't know who i am at all they have
no clue who i
am i become essentially this sort of uh
reflection of the person that i'm
talking to sam in a trucker's cab
he could kill me i could kill him it
didn't happen either
in either form but it's like you become
that person in a way
and everywhere you go there's there's
this heightened sense of need
though where there's not this latency of
like you're two people at a party
and you have to find something to say
and you dig it's just like
okay my life depends on me being social
my life depends on
like i don't have a place to sleep i
don't have a bed i'm going to have to
talk to people and be social
there's this really powerful rawness and
immediacy of intuition that's like
i need to socialize to find what i need
and that's life without money
that's life without you know any of the
trappings or the fast passes or whatever
of this
world the materialized forms that allow
us to sort of transcend this natural
state
that you need that latency goes away
quickly because it's
you will die without it you know that
latency of
it's like fight or flight but it's like
socialize or die that's it that's be
social
be together realize togetherness realize
that no matter
the person you're talking to you need to
connect with them you need to
or you could die and so it's like no
matter who they are if they're a
murderer i've talked to murderers
and i've loved them you know i've talked
to sex offenders
and loved them you know and realized all
these people all these bad people i've
talked to
highly successful business people who
have exploited the world and blah blah
blah i've talked to all kinds of
different people and i
it's like there's this really
interesting dependent position
as a traveler as somebody without money
without the means to
you know be self-reliant self-reliant
that i need these people and it that
latency erodes every time you do that
every interaction
where you don't put that latency that
instantaneous judgment
oh do i like you do i give you my
attention no you give it to everyone
equally
but it's it's interesting that things
optimize you find the place where you're
really really supposed to be
when you listen not to what's going on
around you but you are that water you
are that water going into the room so
wherever you are
wherever you go water is efficient you
know it will find its channel it will
find its way back like electricity
will find its way through a circuit in
the most effective way fungus will do
that too
they'll instinctively find their way the
most effective and intuitive
pathway through life to find the
resources to find what they need and
what we really need is that sense of
connection
we though not just me we
not just you not just i not not any not
just you the listener
we and all of this enlightenment
awakening
realization becomes so much easier when
we shift out of that space
because there is no you there is no me
it really isn't they're nonsense they
make no sense and if you
you know you can go and sit under a tree
i'm not saying that in a dismissive way
i mean you can meditate you can go and
look inside
to the point where you realize you don't
really exist but it's actually quicker
to just travel through the world and and
leave your you know narrative of who you
are and real like in your actual organic
interactions with people realize
who is the person that comes out oh it's
fluid there is no like
set me there's no thing that i would say
in this situation i'm not a character in
a book
there's just you know the most truthful
truthful thing to say there's the most
truthful way to be
and i think really yeah let's go back to
this
i was going to say ridding our society
of this of this narrative that we have
is is the way to get back to that
i think middle way man way middle way is
the way
there there is a u there but at the same
time there isn't any use frank is there
ever
anything happening that's not the middle
way isn't it auto middleweight
all the time but yeah anyways
it's auto middle weighing but yeah keep
going what were you saying self
what is what way
neither neither um asceticism
nor indulgence in worldly places yeah
that's what i'm trying to say yeah
because um i mean i mean it's not it's
not like we can't have money it's not
like you know we just gotta live a
complete modern society well a moneyless
society doesn't mean asceticism
getting past money means actually
economizing our resources
and and intelligently distributing
distributing them in the most efficient
way not in a way where it's hoarded
so that everyone can have everything
that they need and actually more
i could i mean if that's what we want to
talk about i could i have the vision of
that it's not a sacrifice
it's not we need to live in the dirt
again it's it's we can live in
an extremely high tech efficient
powerful
beautiful elegant society
because that's our limitation that's not
what's giving us that's not what's
supporting us
you know the powers that we have that's
what's limiting them that's what's
driving things to death
but the first oh that's funny because so
so isn't bitcoin like a way to
decentralize money yes
yes so is bitcoin a good thing
yes all cryptocurrency
all decentralization of centralized
infrastructure
in general is a good thing
yeah yeah so decentralization is the
middle way
decentralization is dependent
origination
it is fundamental yeah yeah
yeah atlas and i were talking about kind
of trojan horsing these spiritual
principles
into media into movies into books into
podcasts and things like that like
my podcast one of the society is
although we do we have discussed
spiritual
you know aspects we like our recent
episode our most recent episode that's
coming up tomorrow
is with two uh war veterans and they're
talking about imperialism and the
military-industrial complex and
you know the ways that the financial
system and the the profit motive
motivates wars you know one of them said
beautifully that
this is a spiritual war that we're in
we're in a spiritual war
and every man woman child and every
other kind of living
life form on this earth is you know in
the crossfire of that
is is has the gun to their head
collectively
it's it's this yeah yeah
awesome so this is zach's
podcast on youtube everyone the links
will be in the bio below
moneyless society click this one with
the red
the woman in red i made this video too
you don't have to play the sound just
play
just for a second i shot all this
oh the audio is not playing that's okay
just a little tease
[Music]
yeah it's a show that's it's not overtly
spiritual but i think it is for me this
is the most
prime prime uh protecting you it's
affecting your children it's affecting
every single life on this planet
it didn't start here in america it
started long before the americas
did we inherently know what we were
doing no matter how
blatant the destruction that we are
causing we cling to archaic legislation
and belief systems that perpetuate the
destruction that we're causing
that this is why we killed the world for
what
for money it's the system itself i don't
think they're doing enough on time
without trying to really put some of
those systems in check
or completely eradicate them and in
essence make them obsolete with better
models at the same time
it's not sustainable at all the grains
in the hourglass are running out
every single day every second we talk
the end is moving closer
what are the chances of us actually
doing enough here i see
zero reason to believe that the
situation will change we're at the
hottest point
ever we are experiencing extinction die
off rate that is 10 000 times faster
than the natural
path it's simply a matter of how bad
will it get
and and people don't realize we only
have a few years you guys
that i believe in in one thing i believe
in life i believe in nature i believe in
this earth itself
maybe i will go to my death believing
that but i would rather go to my destiny
than accepting that this is it solutions
exist
this is in its own dark and twisted way
is the greatest opportunity
that we have ever had and as we come
together i i really truly believe
we can do this we can fix this we can
truly create a utopia out of this
doomsday scenario okay i'm getting
nervous like i'm a kid on
one individually and collectively faced
with this
let's do it let's save the world we have
to
the intuitive path it's the only path
yeah check us out um we i think we have
a really completely fresh perspective
that it's not one ideology versus
another it's
common sense it's intuitive it's it's
for me it's a very spiritual work
it's the most spiritual thing that we
can do is to change our systems because
all of the you know we look at the
hippie movement or the conscious
movement we look at all these
you know spiritual movements that have
occurred in history they just end up
kind of changing
not they don't they don't they change
things on the surface level but they
don't really go for the the deep root
and even in our society today where you
have spiritual people who have drank
ayahuasca
30 times i met this cat work on the mary
anne williamson campaign and
i won't name his name but he i was like
he was like you mentioned ayahuasca i
was like
wow you've done this this spit this very
special beautiful thing you drank from
the [ __ ] holy grail i did that
and he was like yeah i've done it 30
times you know maybe get on my level
it was just like maybe do it again with
different people maybe check your ego
next time
it's like how can you drink ayahuasca 30
times and still just be an [ __ ]
still be a total egotist it's because
those core beliefs
are completely unquestioned and every
single aspect of our physical
structural society reinforces
individualism disconnection
separation and domination which are not
intuitive to who we are
i people think i'm crazy for talking
like this you know
maybe they do i don't know i don't i
don't really have a good sense of myself
i really don't i just kind of i just
throw myself into these situations and
i just do what i got to do and i
hopefully people are resounding to it i
think
i think it it's a message that needs to
come out
that we need to change and we can and
it's not a
it's not aestheticism it's not
retreating it's going forward
how do you feel about that frank um
i don't i don't really have any thoughts
on that
i had to ask emptiness to empty itself
out
um yeah just do whatever makes you happy
bro
that's what i can say
if you're doing something that's not
hurting people it makes you happy and
passionate about
then that's great that's that's the
that's that's the thing
i think i think it's strange to me that
more people aren't
don't feel called and i'll do it on
instagram i'll put out calls to action
all the time like what are you doing you
know
what are you doing about this do you
care about this or just saying like we
have to do this we have to
they know they is going to fix this
and our world our way of life our
children's futures are all going to end
if we don't this is not a question this
is a scientific certainty
so it's strange to me that people don't
feel that they don't gravitate to this
they don't answer the call
that that that we we live in this period
in our lives where
the world is coming to an end in a way
you know or
our world is the the way i look at is
just that um
there's no reason why people some people
are into it some others are not
it's just it's going back to causes and
conditions just the way it plays out
right now that happens that the zach
character
cares about this more than some other
characters and some other characters
care about their things
and i just i just don't have any
i guess intellectual rationalization of
why that is or
why anything is
i'm thinking in this moment and i guess
this isn't
a new thought but i'm thinking that you
know
even if someone does meditate or take a
psychedelic or go on a trip or something
that the media of our world the cultural
matrix of our world not the deeper
matrix of all duality
but just this the belief system of our
world the media that we watch
the tv the movies all of this stuff is
telling us a narrative about ourselves
and i think it kind of flushes out the
intuitive and it keeps things in this
level where
i think one people just they're just so
disconnected from themselves
they're truly depersonalized and
selfless in again this weird inverted
way where
they're not truly selfless in the way
that they're realizing that the self is
empty
that there is no real them that they're
you know when they look in the mirror
they're looking at a bunch of particles
and things like that
they're not realizing that on a deep
level they're just kind of they haven't
been introduced to or been thrust into
the experience of life
with enough vigor to really realize
anything about themselves
so when you say you and i do this a lot
i get instagram
you yes you you have to take action or
you're going to die and your children
are going to die and everything around
you is going to burn up
it's like people don't identify with
those words you
it's very strange i'm just i'm just
right now it's catching me with how
strange that is
how weird it is that even in rampant
self-interest
the self-interest of okay i want to live
in a world i want to have a planet to
live on
i want this thing this experience to go
on
they're not activated by that i guess
they're activated
on by their own ways but is it their
ways or is it a
a societal depersonalization a
conditioning a belief system that's been
inserted into their brain
i mean regardless they're it's it's that
it's just that i don't know is there
really a difference
hard to say i think there is though i
definitely think there is a difference
i i don't there's levels of simulation
you know there's a simulation in a
simulation
and there's a simulation of the
simulation in the simulation in the
simulation
see but i don't think the war was
assimilation i mean the simulation is
simulating
itself it's not it's whatever level
it is it's simulating itself
yeah i think it is a kind of
i think it's very real it's very real
you know it lacks substance or whatever
you know it's it's it's our senses but
you know our sense is kind of radically
reducing
all the particles and all the uh
basically sense data down to something
that we can
make sense of in that way it's it's
simulation but i think it's very rare
well no way here's the simulation but
yeah i guess in a way there's many
different levels of simulation
all happening all the time um but then
at the same time
every simulations is itself because
at whatever level it is it's still just
itself doing its thing
so yeah i guess you could say that it's
simulating itself at the same time it's
it's simulating other levels and all
levels assimilating each other so it's
not just like oh there's this world and
there's a copy of it and then we're
trapped in this matrix and we have to
get out of it
it's i think it's a lot more simple than
that
well yeah there's a there's there's a
belief system an economic system that
is is endlessly self-maximizing and
seeks to leverage
uh basically basically it requires a
slave class
a working class wage slavery and those
people
can't be intelligent enough that they
kind of realize that that exists
and i think self-actualized people this
is why the hippie movement or the
student movement
you know the consciousness movement of
the 60s and 70s was so dangerous
that they literally shot people was
because and why psychedelics are illegal
why
just now psilocybin is being legalized
because
self-actualized people can't be
controlled they can't they're not they
don't make good consumers they don't
make good workers
it's really hard this has been one of
the struggles of my life it's been the
greatest
struggle blessing in my life that i'm a
terrible worker for most people because
i can't
just shut my brain off and like box
things and you know
put things and swipe things and i just
i'm not good at doing that and being a
machine of productivity
because i i will i'll i'll see these
fragments of myself in another person
and it blasts me out into some
on some other thing so there is a matrix
and the matrix is a belief system that's
current can
constantly reinforced and engendered by
these uh sort of incentive structures
and monetary forms and things in our
world
sure yeah the the the matrix is the
mayan the maya would do anything to
sustain itself
and the maya is just a collective eagle
it's it's operate on the same under the
same mechanism as
as the ego and anything that isn't part
of the ego will automatically get
demonetized sorry um what's that word
demonic oh demonized humanized yeah
so it's like monetize no really anything
that doesn't oh yeah
it doesn't make money it doesn't make
money for climate change it doesn't make
money
to feed the homeless and to help people
it doesn't make money to give people
free health care
or to you know uh like solar energy i
read this [ __ ] mit
paper the other that was like yeah solar
energy as it becomes cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper it will become unsustainable
because we won't be able to continue
making money off of it it's like that's
why the world is the way that it is
because
of this very strange demon demoniacal
you know materialization of ego which is
funny
[Music]
finding the uh perfection in the
imperfection
well i do i do i do see that i i'm
actually in love with the whole journey
i'm in love with the fact that i'm
alive at a point okay okay so it's
obvious it's obvious
there's simultaneity it's all already
perfect and ineffable and non-dual
and yet there's also the dualistic
perfecting
that's happening where it's shifting
from egoic contracted
architectures and consciousness slave to
money
towards decentralized liberated freedom
individual actualization prosperity it's
just all simultaneity that's all
it is but but the more that attention
turns all the way inward and unites
with its true nature true essence and
focuses on the architectures that are
next generation
for the gen z and
generation alpha for these next young
people that that's exactly sort of the
mentality that we want um that's
that's quote gonna make the most
prosperity
and um abundance moving forward
um one thing yeah i love it one thing
one thing was um there's a question that
i want to answer in the chat
quick but um but right prior to that
um i just want to say because this is
probably this is
directly linked to the question as well
but
is this what we were looking at earlier
is it also related to the hyperbolic
geometry
where in the hyperbolic geometry um
frank have you seen this before
uh yeah we scroll down a little bit
scroll down oh
i like i like uh you can't see what i'm
pointing at
dang it but you know the you know the
style of uh
of geometry where it goes see this gold
one
this gold one yes circles
it's no no no no um other side
right by the grid there we go click that
oh that's lovely
yeah that's really it it's all
intermeshed you know it's all woven
together
is that is that sort of similar the
hyperbolic geometry view
to um the indra's net and uh
is that resonant for you and then you'll
see this question frank
is that resonant for you yeah i saw the
picture you showed us earlier about the
the thousand eye thousand arm buddha
it's so yeah pretty
yes yes as [ __ ] yes yes exactly bro
exactly okay here's the question
this is from um alexander apostolov
frank how do you reconcile the
computational leg
between two co-dependent states
in your consciousness that you perceive
as to be co-dependent as everything is
co-arising
what is the reconciliation mechanism
frank do you understand the question
like what is the a giving rise to b what
is the the middleweight middle stage
that
causes a to uh affect
b is that the question i i i think i
think what the question is is around
like
if there is a is there a computational
leg between codependent states in your
consciousness
no no everything is arising
simultaneously all sensations everything
uh that's why i said at the ultimate
level even dependent origination is
is just the concept i mean it's just
another
it's just a tool for you to access the
natural state because in the natural
state
i mean there are links sure but the
links are it's it's not like you stop
and think about how all this causes that
these
during the contemplation you can but
after a while just things are just
happening
right you're you're just those webs and
even that webs is
it's not like there's a time that's what
we talked about earlier it's not like
there's a delay between
uh the cause and effect on the ultimate
level just like how zack said the the
film
when you edit the film it's all laid out
continuously and it's all is this
simultaneously
so in a sense in my experience there's
no lag at all between anything
everything's happening without delay so
there's that and then this is the
follow-up is because if there was no
computational lag
there would be no space for
consciousness to exist
no leftover entropy from building higher
order control structures on top of each
other
well yeah well i mean on the relative
level there there is sequences and
and cause and effect because there is
time is based on the relative level
and yes and then on the ultimate level
uh consciousness not like that's why i
said knowing that the consciousness is
not a space thing it's not like you know
consciousness space like it's not space
so that's why that's why the the thing
we talked about earlier in the other
episode that knowing the empty cogniti
cognition of of things the empty
cognitive it's not really it's it's
completely formless
formlessness doesn't even have space
exactly so even consciousness is
deconstructed
right so it's not like consciousness is
this bubble where there is form and
stuff there's properties
so in a sense from that strict level
there's no consciousness
yeah so i guess i don't answer that
question so
once again yeah the connections are
computational lag of the universe
that's the limit of how it can how do
you reconcile that well
what connections are the computational
lag of the universe that's the limit of
how
code dependent everything can be i don't
understand that question
i think what the indication is trying to
talk about
is the um
how codependent everything can be is
dependent on the computational lag
and i and i don't know how the
computational like plays in like the
maybe the refresh rate is something that
we could maybe
explore talking about where there's a
greater refresh rate
when you're more free and if you're more
contracted
yeah there's less of a refresh rate
exactly that's not the thing we talked
about earlier how there if there's no
center there's no agency there's no doer
everything is there's no delay so
there's no competition there's no lag in
a sense there's no computational lag in
the state of enlightenment
so you don't we can sell you can
reconcile it before enlightenment after
enlightenment you don't reconcile any
delay because there is no lag
it's it's interesting to say that
because it's like when somebody is in
that state of extreme like poverty or
deprivation or scarcity
where um they're in that reactive state
they're just reacting to everything
and there's no latency or
breath or frame or space between the
thing that happens to them
and their reaction which is just it it's
in its own weird way
it's water you know they're like water
they're being like water
in the most sort of inverted and toxic
sense that this depersonalized mindless
public
that is kept that way through the system
is you know there is no latency between
their interaction and their reaction to
the world
um i would say that um that okay there's
i guess there's three levels
first level is like there there's even
reaction itself
there's a process there right there's a
process that's um
a survival mechanism you know there's a
lot of layers and a lot of lenses to
understand it
yeah people just react something happens
to somebody they react they don't
stop and think and question the system
that brought them there or the
you know uh the co-dependent origination
of
of all the things that happened to get
them there they just react they
they are separated from you know the
enmeshedness connectedness of everything
into that one thing
that's very interesting because i think
the um the the awakened state is kind of
like that
it's it's you just it's not like i
wouldn't call it a reaction but it just
happened
it's like you don't stop and think about
anything you don't you don't even try to
observe thoughts
so in a sense that the awakened state in
the completely non-awaken state is
almost exactly alike
except it's completely different an
analogy that i always use is watching tv
versus being in the tv
you can watch the tv and react to tv but
if you're in the movie you don't
it's like the movie's just happening
without it
in a way it's it's it's kind of like
reacting to things because you don't
think about anything
but things are still happening so it's
like it's the reaction that unfolds
through
but that it's harmonized
it's the same thing react it's a wheel
yeah
spinning yeah it's the same thing
reacting to itself yeah right
right yes cube it's not a billiard ball
being right by the crew
into something else it's just it's like
perpetual motion
yeah it's a it's a just is
and i think that's that's kind of the
state that we can all attain you know in
every aspect of our life
okay okay this is this is a great way to
bring this in to what you were just
sharing which is that
you know alexander shared this as well
the dimension in which your
enlightenment exists is fundamentally a
control structure in of itself that has
a leg due to the principle
of entangled complexity which you can
google quantum mechanics
is the leg so one of the ways that you
can potentially
um view the seven and a half
billion people or however many people
feel like they might
have a more contracted energy
in that maybe feel like they're
slaves to the economic system
um yeah yeah there's there's something
there that is so
also interesting not only on an like on
a conscious
uh becoming conscious or becoming aware
and gaining metacognition and then
pursuing
truth or enlightenment or whatever but
that even on uh
on just a on a on a fundamental even
physics or energetic level
that there's a degree of
there's a degree of contraction versus a
degree of liberation
and we're we're figuring out yeah and
we're figuring out what's going on here
as well in terms of
the connectomics when you look at eeg
or fmri and you look at things that
these biomarkers that show you if people
are in more coherent states of
consciousness or
or dissonant states of consciousness so
a dissonant state is very
anxious depressed contracted um
and so there's a lower quantum
mechanical something
that we have to figure out like
something that's going on there
versus when there's potentially maybe
its potentiality
is a big part of it the potential like
the little
like in um quantum mechanics you see
there's probabilities
right and so you have greater
probabilities and less contraction
when the awakened states are present
and so then the biomarkers are around
coherence they're around
they're more around flow they're less
around anxiety
and so that spontaneous expression that
that frank keeps talking about it it
only comes
from knowing mind nature knowing mind
essence
it only comes from rick it only comes
from this natural
state of seeing everything as
the dependent origination as the single
one intelligence endlessly infinitely at
play with itself
and that's what enables the expression
to be pure service
um but on a level of sort of getting
there
the contracted energy goes on these
things like heroes journeys when it sees
that it can liberate itself to greater
possibilities
like there's a there's a bio biometric
shift inside of you that happens in your
nervous system
when you do shift into pursuing the
hero's journey
or similarly when you
um become aware of yourself
watching your thoughts like the
metacognition
so you basically get a central nervous
system upgrade
frank talks about this like this
contemplative ai that starts kicking in
more and more and more over time and so
you
you gain more sovereignty and more
and more awareness of the thought clouds
appearing and disappearing
and then you get this again there's like
this decontractive shift
where now like you were saying on the
when marlo started the show
that as soon as the train comes to a
stop and is being delayed
all you do is go
and because you're not reactive you're
not impulsive you're not
contracted and so there there is a deep
deep um relationship with energy
um and that we're discovering on a level
of quantum mechanics that is
still blowing people's um minds that
everything is this no
thing that is appearing as something
at play with itself is just [ __ ]
insane
um and so now there's the
differentiation between contraction
versus liberation yeah yeah that's
actually a thing
i was just gonna say the difference
between just to put all that into a very
practical kind of
sense it's like the difference between
anxiety and freedom
is very thin it's it's razor thin i mean
it's really a perspective shift that
it's like okay i lost my job or i broke
up with my
my girlfriend my partner it's this thing
happened to me
that set me off what i thought was my
path and
and the problem in that situation is
life spreading out in probabilities that
out
far outnumbered the radical reduction of
what we
thought was life was was the trajectory
was my purpose i was supposed to do this
blah blah blah these
rationalizing insanities that keep us
from basically
clinging to that one thing that isn't
anymore
oh i was supposed to get to the train on
time and then we start to get anxious
whereas it's like okay i'm not going
where i thought i was supposed to go
or i have this road sprawled out in
front of me
you know i could go anywhere i could do
anything that's the shift
is in seeing in that moment of latency
it's instead of
not to create this arbitrary duality of
either you go here or you go here but i
think this exists on a biochemical level
that it's like when someone feels safe
when their needs are met
or when they are even in a place where
their needs are not met but their deeper
sort of sense of self is sort of
insulated in that kind of myelin sheath
that
insulated protective layer that allows
them to look at that
expanse of the world out there above
them not as an oppression
of possibilities that they can't fathom
and control
but an adventure of endless
possibilities anything could happen
and it's like i think when you really
step into that place that adventure of
anything can happen
this great it starts to write itself
like the ai it starts to write itself
you start to see
this is scripted this is too perfect
this is too
good you know and your intentions and
you know to get into
manifestation and all these things that
have been totally co-opted to be become
like
you know selfishness and i want this car
and i want this
material thing and i want my success and
blah blah blah blah when you set this
pure intention
you know reality itself around you
changes to sort of meet that
in a very freaky way and synchronicities
start to pop up
and i think those synchronicities on on
this adventure of life you know they're
like
they're like the little clues or they're
like they're like crystal gems or
whatever
whatever the structure of the video game
that our existence is that lets us know
that we're going in the right direction
when things just seem meant to be
and it's impossible to say that to
somebody who goes around with this
belief system that
life is oppressive life is meaningless
you know there's no god there's no
you know anything beyond what we can
observe materially even though quantum
physics
is is you know breaking the breaking the
the uh
roof off of all of that of all of that
reductive thought
that we've proven that there's no god we
have science what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
quantum physics has proven that
everything we thought we knew we don't
and that's liberating that shouldn't
scare you because it breaks your
narrow conception of what you thought
was we have only to discover
how limitless we truly are
you know i like the last thing you said
about um yeah we just don't really know
what the [ __ ] is going on that's freedom
um yeah so yeah just
the difference like you said the
difference between anxiety
or the ego versus you know infinity or
the state of god is just the contraction
and expansion of uh sensations energy
that's all there is to it you know it's
the same sensation it's the same
particles it's the same energy
but when it's contracted is the ego when
it's expended it's
um you know christ consciousness or
whatever you know
yeah and yeah
god love love god you know i'm sure
there's a there's a
a sanitized you know uh scientific way
to put that
okay if if the nature really
truly boils down to this
is all one intelligence exploring
infinite potential the universe is a
mechanism for us to explore some of it
and then as that the zero point energy
or the no
thing as it
fluctuates in its expression
in its manifestation into something
into this play that this is that there
are individuated contracted
egoic separate energies that don't know
their first link nature of knowledge
and then there's the other expression
which is
completely decontracted completely
liberated completely expansive
completely free
because it knows the first link
which is knowledge of mind essence
that's what is that's potentially what
this
whole if that is this whole fabric
of what this looks like then the most it
seems like the most important thing that
can happen
is to incrementally shift people or even
rapidly if possible to shift people from
contracted to expansive and entheogens
are one of the best
fastest ways to like open that up but
there's also um you know there's things
like micro
dosing on on magic mushrooms for a
single gram that can
that can begin that opening process that
are 100 percent
safe um but also just meeting people's
basic needs
and meeting
fundamentals yes yes yes and those are
those are crystal clear
given um i would i would go
more into the realm right now
of seeing who are the people on the
planet
that have the most wealth
and influence and that or
media um again influence
or that run the largest corporations or
that are the
um presidents of countries this type of
stuff
and i would see if there are ways to
shift
their expression from the contracted
separate
to the expanse of infinite free and to
see their fellow
employees and their million followers as
actually their brothers and sisters
because that creates a faster i feel
like
as you meet basic needs from the bottom
up you can also create the top-down
consciousness expansion
that then makes the architectures that
already exist
like we're talking about the presidents
that run
countries across the world or the
fortune 500 ceos or the
you know there's there's 2 200
billionaires
you know how many of them have ever
tasted uh uh
anything that's transpersonal 100
200. here's an interesting thing that
grimes uh
the uh wife of uh elon musk is
apparently very
into dmt and she's actually bought an
island this may be total hearsay he's
bought an
island to basically grow or
you know raise the toads that uh produce
5mao dmt
so it's what's very interesting to me
and i've experienced i've seen this
before you know i've seen people take
you know very powerful substances
ayahuasca included
which i used to think you know if
everybody just took ayahuasca or
everybody took i
acid we would be beyond this but it's
like
for some reason i'm i'm reminded of a
debate i had years ago with
a friend of my mom so is this very
deeply conservative
has this very abhorrent world view and i
i
roundly like beat him in this debate or
not beat him but we got i got him to the
to realize like okay
this is what you're actually advocating
this is the penultimate
you know end of your world view your
system is
the extraction of all resources into the
hands of the smallest percentage of
people
in in it with the conde with the
opportunity cost of a dead earth
and those small people get into
spaceships and they go to earth and they
flee
and leave everyone else to die and he
was basically just like
you're right you're actually right he
said that he said you're right you know
the unthinkable in a debate
and then we just buddied out and had fun
but you know what happened after that
was
he went back into his life where he's
surrounded by people who know him as a
person who has these views
and then he goes back to his job where
he has to treat his employees in a
certain
way he goes back to his social system
his
his uh you know politics his party his
all of these things
that continually reinforce him to back
into that beliefs
that belief that he has so these people
in this powerful position
if they had some awakening and
uh you know shifted began to shift
things toward a certain
degree because i think that this is the
problem with thinking that even even an
individual with massive power
cannot basically override a system
around them
so i i don't think i don't know i think
we but we need to work on people at all
levels because it's not like
rich good poor bad i think at the very
highest
you study people's brains they're rigid
contracted they're not
they actually stop registering the
emotions of people around them if they
have enough power wealth and influence
and the same thing of people at the very
bottom of wealth that they are in that
you know rigid contracted state so it's
like
we need to work on people at all levels
and realize we're all victims of culture
that there are there is that the reason
the way the world is isn't because of
individualized moral failures or
individualized moral salvation
it's because of this system this is the
social system and the incentive
structure
that has been placed into this world
that makes it the way that it
is so it basically we are operating on
an algorithm
we have an ai that is running our world
that is basically converting life into
debt
life into profit and we need to change
that we need to change that system
and how we go about doing that is really
the hardest question of all
we need to basically reprogram our
collective ai
and realign it with this natural
principle with natural law essentially
and create you know and we can use ai to
do that we don't need
markets and things like that to manage
uh
resources we we have the technology to
make that question of like oh who
are you putting in charge of that we
have an ai that we survey the resources
that exist in the earth
this is a resource-based economy we
survey the resources that exist on our
earth we have an artificial intelligence
an ai
or you know just even an algorithm a
computer a calculator
that you know basically moderates and
manages resource use
production development and essentially
uses that to meet the needs not
the base needs not the number of
calories that are needed the real
spiritual
personal humane culinary all the needs
of humanity
to the point where we are all operating
at our best level
to where we are all functioning at a
place where we're all able to
to collectively work together in society
to evolve things beyond fossil fuels
beyond these rustic you know antiquated
thousand-year-old financial systems and
mercantile systems of trade and
all this [ __ ] and get us to the point
where we're working to
bring everybody there there's no
guillotine that's needed there's no
person
that is beyond fixing and changing but
it requires a collective shift it takes
a village
it takes people being surrounded and and
uh conditioned
and nurtured at all sides so that they
don't lapse back into the old way of
thinking because it's so deep
the thing about the uh whatever that guy
asked me about um
um yeah i love that
the atlas we have three people that are
so weird here
you're like the straight man so
this is him this is him frank yeah
alexander mentioned he enjoyed our three
convos
yeah no i wanted to answer his question
i i didn't i didn't answer this question
um he said something about quantum
mechanics and i can google it
see i want to point out the distinction
between the direct experience
of realization and the mechanics of it
because like yeah this question because
it's it's it's kind of like asking
sam ball is sprinting really fast and
he's in that zone where he's like
sprinting like nine seconds to cover 100
meters
he's not going to think about the
mechanics of that he's not going to look
in his muscle and look at
his the cells and be like what's making
my speed happen
i think that's a really big confusion um
between
between uh the the whole the system of
science and the
direct experience of the meditation of
uh
realizations
i don't know if that makes sense okay
okay one more time the difference
between
the scientific approach versus the
realization by direct
experience is what yes yes i think it's
just
is what though is based on what
it's it's one of the most mis uh
misunderstand
misunderstood uh differences on the path
no i know but what was you what was your
like core
essence of how to differentiate when
somebody is
understanding the nature based on um
quantum mechanics or entanglement versus
yeah yeah yeah
oh well it's like using boss sprinting
the directive experience of running
hundred meter dash in nine seconds
versus
reading a book about it or distincting
the muscles uh and look for the
mechanics of what gives rise to the
speed
that's the difference oh oh oh i see
okay what yeah oh interesting
i was just trying to point out that
question is completely relevant to
to awakening that's so good
yeah so because all his questions are
based on the presumption that
direct experience is the same as the
mechanics of direct experience
but they're not they're on two different
levels
i just want to make that clear because i
can't answer that question because i
don't know what gives rise to this i
don't have no
[ __ ] clue how this is infinite like
is it the brain or is it like quantum
mechanics is it like
what nerves because writers i don't care
it doesn't
it's not relevant to the world it's like
frank you said you said uh
one of the first questions i asked you
when we started filming because frank
and i've been working on uh
the frank yang the movie for quite some
time now and we were in the gym
and i had you know i kind of had an idea
i was i'm an idealist that's my stance
just my where's where i'm at
and i was like frank what came first
mind or matter and i was kind of
expecting him to say
oh of course mind comes first not matter
and he said
neither you basically said that the body
is the brain
and and i i think that's a beautiful way
of kind of uh putting it into the most
the meatiest way of uh kind of
understanding that
that the the you know mind and matter
they need each other they are creating
each other like
the matrix the material world is the
computer it's the hardware
the software is consciousness like how
would you have a conscious experience
a world or like a reality for it to
experience and then also how would you
have a world
or a reality without consciousness
experience it's such a
simple thing once you get the
realization it's so
simple it's like a child it's like
explain like i'm five
it's so simple once you get that
materialism or physicalism and
consciousness or awareness
are one thing it's so simple once you
get that
simple right yeah
it's just like how understanding
independent origination just answers
at least a lot of questions about why
this happens why is this happening how
is this happening
um it's the same with what you just said
about how minor matter are one and you
just stop analyzing
what comes first might create
consciousness what is consciousness
right like at some point all that stuff
just becomes like mental masturbation
and you just don't think about it yeah
you just cut it makes sense
you just get it really that's it it just
yeah you just like once you get it you
don't
you don't analyze it anymore because you
don't analyze what you already
understand
the questionnaire dissolves yeah yeah
both the answer and the question
dissolved well the question is and but i
think the curiosity remains and there's
only curiosity driving it yeah but
that's true
that drove it to know itself and then it
ends
and then it ends to know yourself
completely and then you dissolve
your urge the fire and the the seeking
it does it's not the the seeking ends
but then the the knowing
deepens yeah right right exactly the the
unfoldment deepens after you stop trying
to figure it out with the mind
that's why i always say to god realize
you have to make god disappear
to realize the self you make the self
disappear to realize anything you
absorb the transcendent you don't see
anymore
carl jung was talking about the ego um
as if there's a really beautiful
uh talk by alan watts where he talks
about carl jung and he actually knew
carl jung so he's like he's like oh yes
carl was this way and he was this way
and
he talks about he had this glimmer in
his eye this uh
element of irreducible rascality where
he understood intuitively like
that all humans are capable of all good
and bad at the same time that he didn't
judge people like that
oh there was a really specific thing
that he was saying that he said
oh yeah he said in dealing with a
patient who is suffering from an ego
you can't diminish the ego you can't
break it up like you're breaking up a
kidney stone or something
you have to basically encourage it and
push it to the end
you have to push it to it enantiodromia
that's his term the beautiful big
beautiful ten syllable word the
enantiodromias when you push something
so far in one direction
it goes all the way around the other
totally and it's totally
that's exactly that's what we're doing
with our system in this world the
the enantiodromia of you know expansion
and extraction and selfishness
self-interest we're doing this to the
world where
we need to really just come out the
other side we need to we need to
continue
pushing this self-interest to the point
where we realize self-interest
is to fundamentally value the life of
everyone around you
that you personally have a lot more to
gain
from everyone around you coming up with
you and gaining with you
and that that we can't even imagine our
potential right now
with this master slave dynamic that is
limiting the vast majority of human
beings from experience from having from
even be able to fathom a conversation
like this
you know like like if they were that's
why we just would just insult them
they'd just be like oh i feel stupid or
i'm not smart enough for this when
everyone is smart enough to have these
conversations that's why we're here
to sit here and just just giggle and
you know dig into the festoon glimmering
glowing guts of what it is to be
and to ask these big essential questions
of like
just why not why this why that why
why do i exist or why do i why you know
just taking these questions apart and
figuring out really better questions to
ask we can't ask those questions
and answer them until we basically wake
down all of us
we can't wake up all the way up until we
wake all the way down we can't wake all
the way down until we wake all the way
up
so it's like this this cycle that i that
that uh the geometry that that image
really stuck with me of those
intertwining snakes you know of the
darkness kind of forming the light and
the bad forming the good
and all of it kind of coming together
coalescing into this beautiful story
that the the beginning of which is the
seed of the end and the end there'd be
no beginning without an end
and there's really no end endless
sequels you know endless uh
spin-offs endless new tales new journeys
new adventures
um that's why i think the point you made
about just exhausting the ego until it
blows up i think that's why
that's why i don't think i think nature
will course correct itself so like
that's why we are nature and we are the
correction yeah so that's why if you
keep pushing capital
to the end point and it's going to
deconstruct itself and that's what
that's what's happening right now all
those movements that you're talking
about all this like you know
collective awakening that's happening is
because of that
and we are nature it's because it's it's
adapter died i mean and that's
mutation and [ __ ] and mistakes are
the keystones
of evolution as we know it i don't think
we really understand evolution that well
i mean i think natural selection is a
silly thing
i mean ecosystems evolve together they
evolve
a role that is needed for the collective
to exist within
so it's like but but evolution you know
that mutation that
thing that comes out that seems like a
mistake the thumb the extra digit
you know there was a there was an ape
that evolved this extra digit
and did they make fun of him were they
like what are you you freaking he's like
oh no it makes me better
that we are at a point where we have
evolved this tumorous
growth of all this crazy excess and
waste and destruction
and all of it can be used and channeled
and recycled into something
that we can't imagine oh yeah i gotta
um read my basketball post real quick
before you yes
yeah let's wrap yeah we will wrap um let
me also just pull it up because i have
it
um because i think this relates to
everything we're talking about so it's
like the last video we could sum it up
with just something that's more
organized
okay hold on hold on i sent you i i
don't i i i know what
what i what i want to do is i want
people to watch this first do should
they watch the video first frank or do
you
want to read the po uh i don't really
mind
this whatever i mean it does it's not
really related
it's somewhat related a little bit but
anyway okay let's give them
let's give them am i watching okay
yeah this is frank yang's dreamscape
it's beautiful
i mean i just kind of download it i mean
i edit it a little bit
so i'll just read the post real quick
okay all right all right so this is at
at least you have this
for background okay so now here's the
post you can read it from here if you
want yeah
i'll read it okay so i turned on the tv
to watch an nba game for the first time
in a decade
today's nba is like a video game that
constantly updates itself with players
that have no identities yeah they're
scoring more points than all stars from
the past generations team started joel's
20 years ago made it to the
playoffs and deep deep boston deep into
it dominated by players that are
anonymous unless you follow the game all
superstars are limited from the playoffs
later i turn on the tv and watch the nba
finals
like who the [ __ ] are those players man
it's about this buffon curry
the anonymity enters the matrix
accumulating with kobe's death and
epidemic were now inside the alternative
universe
the game has been moved from big man
dominating in the center
to beyond the three-point line players
are no longer confined to their specific
roles
and all positions are shape-shifting
superstar athletes like consciousness of
the buddha
sorry superstar athletes of
consciousness like buddha
christ and gurus like mj's are a thing
in the past
there are no more dynamities anyone can
win a championship now
likewise thanks to the internet
enlightenment is now available to the
common man
some of the most infinite cons i know
are not teachers or gurus
but normies with no followers or profile
pics meditators are the athletes of
consciousness
when you reach the end point there's
nothing for the universe flexing itself
lock kelly said that the first glimpse
he had of 4k 360 awareness which is
nature was when he was playing sports if
ever
ever if every nba player attained high
quality
their game would be next level panoramic
coordination by default even when you're
[ __ ]
athletic abilities and consciousness
levels are involved side by side
sprinters are getting faster
bodybuilders are getting more juicy and
thoughts have bigger glutes
slam down contests and sneakers are more
psychedelics than ever
different players have their own unique
style to accomplish the same goal which
is putting the ball in the basket
different practices from different
traditions and
different ideologies lead to different
phenological and perception shifts at
the end
and different flavors of realization and
mystical experiences all lead to
enlightenment which has no levels
why are you laughing it's just i'm doing
my powerpoint presentation brah
i delight in every every utterance every
every letter
every uh intonation the way that you
jiggle when you do it
i just love you man i love your ability
to uh pursue a metaphor until it's unto
its endangerment to really
do like we did in the laundromat and the
laundromat to really like find the
infinite in the mundane
and that for me is like my ultimate
spiritual practice is filmmaking because
it's like i was talking to atlas before
you jumped on we thought you were having
like a monstrous poop um and i know how
you poop so
we're not gonna go into it now but you
know it's like getting them getting oh
yeah
you know my yeah it was good you'll see
it someday world
but uh like for me to my meditation my
external meditation is looking at the
world through the camera
and zooming into these little these
little small details
that are expressive of you know the
immensity of everything you know that
you find the infinite in anything if you
zoom in close enough
and getting into the macro lens gets you
even closer to that where you see
a pile of dust and that's the entire
galaxy that's the entire universe that
exists within you that
that that's for me is is to look outward
and to see
to seek that in everything and your
ability to see that to see
infiniteness in basketball players
running around a screen which to me
would just be completely absurd i would
i wouldn't i would have to really
struggle to find that you know and i
think that's so
wonderful that our we're specialized in
that we're specialized in this
essentialized role
of awareness becoming aware of itself
that we all perceive something that
others wouldn't
that the i think filming is very
interesting because like when you look
at the as a director
as a person watching the film it's kind
of like not it's kind of like union
locality
it's kind of like just consciousness
just floating around right because when
you know it doesn't take
sometimes it does but it doesn't really
take a perspective of you know one
specific character so much is like you
know
how the the cut of the movie it's kind
of like a dream where you just kind of
decentralize you know there's
this the camera is here and i was there
and i was there and i was thinking of
the instead of mine
helicopter sean i was listening so it's
kind of like the
critical witness you know the watching
the movies kind of be participating in
the god witness
in a sense and then you're you're doing
it with the finite through the mundane
and the infinite
yeah it's you're creating something
you're creating a myth and a narrative
out of reality that wasn't there before
or was always there waiting to be
realized
and it's like it's it's really it's
truly a quantum process
that changes things when you take out
the camera i was talking about this with
a friend today
even if you don't release what you sho
have shown because the
vast majority of the stuff i've shot and
frank and i have [ __ ] hours and hours
and hours of awesome [ __ ]
that we're gonna release someday you
know about how frank yang became this
thing how i became this thing through
frank yang becoming this
et cetera you know it's like even
without viewing the movie
the sheer process of whipping the camera
out and this focused form of observation
of gazing into reality intently with an
intent
to find meaning in it with an intent to
find that you're going to find it even
if it isn't there and that's
it it's a quantum process that splits
these particles into waves
and it changes the outcome of reality
not even just at what you focus on when
you bring the camera out when you bring
intention into your life
not just it is beyond the metaphor of
the camera when you intentionally
cultivate awareness life outside of you
of your own individualized localized
perception
shifts and changes to meet you where you
are to find you and to connect with you
that's why we're having this
conversation right now it's a really
strange thing that
i message frank yang on instagram two
years two or three years ago
you know and frank connected atlas and i
we started messaging each other
on instagram we've had very a very you
know to frail connection as opposed to
you know
most people who talk they meet each
other at work they
talk to somebody see them every day but
they don't have a conversation like this
they don't connect at this level
and that's what we're being limited from
that we're not all able to have these
conversations at this deep heart level
that we're not able to
puncture the veil of the mundane that we
live in this mundane world but it's not
it's amazing it's a miracle it's
incredible it's unfathomable that we
exist
the way that we do and i just want to
see everyone get there
and i and until until uh that i think
that's the bodhisattva you know
that you could you could achieve
enlightenment and die and
and pass on or or emerge blissfully
but that's it's no fun if you can't
bring others with you
is it we
it's all fun yeah
amen amen
beautiful all right
do you guys feel like we're good like
that was a solid rap
yeah the thing is though you don't you
don't you don't
zoom into the proof from you don't zoom
into the poop
and and then find the the divine
you gotta know that that it's there but
no it's everything yeah it's starting
you
frank you disconnected your your mic
oh yeah so yeah so you don't you don't
you don't really need to zoom
in and then see the particles to find
the divine in the infinite
well but that's just that lens to get
there you know
that's just that's oh yeah that's good
that's the first step
out the door it's already there it's
already there it's waiting for you to
find it it's already scripted the
adventure
people sometimes people spend too much
time on the uh
on the on the on the zooming when they
should be just
you gotta get you gotta you got you need
a zoom and you need a wide angle baby
you need to keep that [ __ ] you know you
know this movie
have you seen this movie called um i
forgot what it's called but it's just
like
static shot of like super wide angle and
there's just characters moving there
there's no there's no centralized story
there's no other there's no
have you seen it about endlessness the
movie says
he's got a trilogy i haven't seen that
one yet yeah that movie man it's so
it's it's perfect now it's the perfect
representation of nevada in samsara
infinite in the finite
it's the perfect analogy i think it's a
more perfect analogy
of enlightenment than matrix or truman
show or anything like that watch this
trailer watch this thing
this is this is so good the entire movie
is just like the
framing and yeah just watch this
there's no centralized characters
there's a little story just things
happening it's just completely absurd
and random
and then you're just like this floating
witness that's just like have no purpose
but it's super beautiful too you know
and everybody everything is closed
yeah it it gets you to see the world
that you overlook
every day for its absurd beauty
[Music]
because i think the world is beautiful
you know it is beautiful how it is
you know without cha it without just
change you know
saying we need to move beyond this ugly
world as it is to the to the world that
is good that is a duality
but it's like uh yeah i mean it it's all
beautiful
it's really beautiful even the tragedy
is beautiful and it forms it in this
non-linear way
that it's like you can't have the
beautiful without the unbeautiful you
know and they're they're completely
interlinked
they're not one in the other ping pong
ball bouncing back and forth between
them
it it is interlinked and i think any
uh in back in that in that um carl jung
video uh that that um oh that's such
that's so
good bro what are you guys no you gotta
watch the whole thing
you gotta watch the whole movie we are
bro that
no that's a for sure definitely going to
watch that holy [ __ ]
real quick because it's like right there
what what did you just say i was
switching it ain't worth it
oh i was saying that that in this in
that carl jung
watts video did you just did did you
just say that this is a representation
of like the jim newman non-duality
no i said that movie is a really good
representation of how how
over the enlightened state nirvana is
samsara that you don't get away from the
suffering alive you you find
you find bliss and beauty in the
suffering of life they exist
simultaneously
so it's not like you zoom in anything or
you go out into the outer world
in midway stages yes you're going to god
consciousness and dmd church but but but
see that movie is a better
representation
of non-duality than like you know movies
like
matrix or like even truman show or like
those trippy movies where you think
oh that's what i mean yeah
yeah but yeah but is it more efficient
for collective awakening
to um prioritize the
dissemination of movies like about
endlessness
that shows people the direct end goal
that samsara and nirvana are one
or i don't think maybe yeah yeah so
that's the question because it does seem
like
in a sense when i watch a video
of people showing me that i'm a sheep
until i become
aware of my thoughts um that is like
[ __ ] i need to become aware of my
[ __ ] thoughts
you know um yeah yeah yeah i know what
you mean yeah
yeah yeah so that's kind of interesting
i kind of think that in in
for you know again ruining it in my own
experience my own art as a movie maker
it's about the middle passage and it's
about making films that
you know show people you know the beauty
of the world as it is the real true
beauty
showing them something they've seen a
million times in their life
with magic in it but also showing you
know using that
that deeper allure that deeper interest
that if we take this interest in our
world
we see it's it's beautiful beyond our
wildest dreams and it's it was always
there it's not around the horizon it's
not like
after the revolution life gets wonderful
it's already wonderful and the process
of getting there is wonderful
but yeah i do think we really need to
focus
people's attention their awareness it's
not just cultivating awareness of
awareness itself
cultivating that awareness to the fact
that this way of life is wrong
is is is is diversive is discursive is
destroying us
and that's what's destroying us it's not
reality itself eating itself in a
random raw crazy way there's a purpose
to it and it's it's a state of
unconsciousness
that we're living in that that it's we
live in an insane universe
that says there is good and evil that
there are good people and bad people
you know we we need to transition to
this non-dual
sense of being a sense of fluidity of
who we are that we aren't one
individualized frame of a person we're
the whole movie
we're the person that changes through
time and that each person
whether they start out this point this
moment of aware awareness
is is gained as the villain or the hero
or the baby
you know we can all get back there
together
we have that fluidity we have that
adaptability in us because that's
essentially who we are we're fluid
we are all the frames we're not stopped
on any one frame we're not the beginning
or the end
or the whole movie we're the whole you
know bliss of the experience and the and
the remembrance of that experience
making movies is my psychedelic it's my
drug it's my
it's my meditation it's it's
consistently what gleans
i glean these insights from by just
awareness raw awareness
saying okay i'm staring at something and
i don't see meaning in it
i need to find the meaning because it's
there if i can't see it
it's just because i'm not looking hard
enough i'm not right i'm not using it
michael kors i love frank too
i'm a big frog fan oh i love you michael
yes
you are my hero
michael is that the hero you see michael
kors that you could be
michael guy from fitness
this is a there's a channel called
michael kor fitness and he was making
recipes
with his mom or something
yeah baby
[Music]
i don't think that guy's hippie man he's
like a call he he's plays the role of
the
the the like the sorority boy no
michael's talking about
marlo oh okay okay okay i thought he's
talking about michael
i think he's talking about marlo yeah
i i i'm no sorry okay that word
i don't fight it anymore it's fine
bro i gotta go you lunch too man i
haven't eaten all day
it's three three p.m yeah we've been
going for two hours we've been going for
a long ass director's cut of a movie
frank alexander would be
interested in um chatting
more so maybe we can uh
check on ig or whatnot i love you too
bro
yeah i'll love you
sami y'all can you can like my uh you
can you can link my instagram here
anybody who wants to
wants to talk or write or whatever wants
to talk
i'll talk to anybody i love people a lot
this is why we do this you know for
other people
i i it's it's part part way to you know
get into a crazy feedback loop with
with these two wonderful you know humans
these two wonderful experiences
but it's like it's yeah it's about
connecting with other people so
please reach out
frank we gotta get together soon baby we
gotta make this movie we gotta go to
europe we gotta go to asia we gotta go
to africa we gotta we gotta travel we
gotta go to india come on we gotta do it
we will we gotta finish that gang
journey
sure
you gotta train me you gotta yoke me up
you gotta get me jacked you gotta teach
me how to eat
yeah we'll work out together alice i'm
gonna co are you gonna be an ella you're
leaving for europe soon so
yeah how long are you gonna be in l.a
yes bro um
probably a about another month or so
and um this was a this was very powerful
like uh just really honing in on
like basic needs was really strong also
holding in on
architectures and decentralization was
really strong
and and um
just our play together us three was
really strong and
it was cool because we also went into
the craziness of
dependent origination but we also went
to
um explore a lot of mainstream stuff in
this collective awakening episode
marlo this was a great first show
together loved having you on brother
any time any time i really lived for
this kind of conversation this kind of
talk this is really
we were talking on the phone before
about like when you find your thing
nothing else compares you know nothing
else feels as good as expressing
yourself
you know and doing your part to serve
this higher purpose this higher sense of
love of connection of
you know the infinite and always here to
always here for that
yeah beautiful and you guys can check it
out
yeah i love you for sure oh i love you
so much
yeah the passion's lit bro you got it
rolling under
under you strong and we have uh the
links in the bio below again to
marlo's youtube channel also his
instagram you can go and give him a
follow subscribe watch his content
um we'll have frank's info down there as
well
and maybe we will be producing more
content soon it's exciting
um the simple analogies have been very
powerful i know
um and so hopefully we can keep doing
that if the video brought you value give
it a like
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet leave us a comment below with your
thoughts
um on the episode we'd love to hear from
you and
share the content with other people that
you feel like this could profoundly
influence and help so that would be
great
you do a thumb do a thumbnail this is a
thumbnail for the video
[Music]
[Music]
and that's that's all fam that's all
thank you infinite love for you guys
thank you
thank you thank you and uh yeah
yeah thank you
thank you alice love you guys will keep
doing more we'll keep doing